So, wollen wir loslegen?
Ja, los, los, los.
3, 2, 1.
Es wundert mich ein bisschen, dass ich da noch keine Werbung eingeblendet kriege. Maxi-Paxi, schönen guten Tag. Achso, nee, du hast noch gar nicht rösten gehabt.
Wir müssen da eine dedizierte Pause kurz machen und so verheißungsvoll mich anschauen. Ja, und jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt geht's los.
Ja, so ist das. Man muss einatmen, innehalten und dann einfach diesen goldenen Moment erzeugen.
Ich wusste, ich hab was vergessen. Ich hab's atmen vergessen.
Gar nicht mal abwarten, einfach erzeugen. Man schafft diesen Moment.
Man schafft Momente. Wir schaffen Momente.
Wir schaffen Momente bei Mobile Max. Und das heißt, willkommen bei unserem zweiwöchentlichen Gückquassel. Und ja, alle Aufnahmegeräte laufen. Das ist sehr zufriedenstellend. Heute dauert es mal wieder ein bisschen, uns hier online zu kriegen. Aber der Chat zuckt im Hintergrund, die Lämpchen blinken. Die Themenlage ist wie immer, mager. Aber es gibt Gerüchte.
Wie lange wird es noch Gerüchte geben?
Wollen wir uns über Gerüchte unterhalten? Aber du kannst dich ja auch erstmal ein bisschen auskotzen, Max. Du hast ja den Hals.
Ja, ich hoffe ihr auch, oder? Ich kenne mal davon aus, dass ihr auch einen Hals habt.
Schweinegrippe?
Na ja, schon auch. Also ich meine, ich bin jetzt nicht mehr so...
Also ich als alter Ossi, ich fühle mich ja wieder wie zuhause quasi, ganz gemäßt.
Ich verstehe nur Bahnhof.
Max hat die Zensursula im Arsch.
Im Arsch? Bist du volljährig?
Es drückt und es schmerzt. Du hast mich neulich per Chat angehauen, ob denn noch irgendjemand irgendwas tun würde. Ich saß und dann habe ich gesagt, keine Ahnung. Und dann ging irgendwie zwei Tage oder zwei Stunden später, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, auf immer hast du deinen Spreeblick geschwärzt.
Nee, das war nicht ich. Das war's für mich? Nee, damit hatte ich gar nichts zu tun.
Ich dachte schon, du wärst dann irgendwie so enttäuscht von dann gezogen, hast dir gedacht, so jetzt mach ich sie alle fertig. Dann hast du dann irgendwie einfach das Block umgehauen.
Nee, das war gar nicht ich. Das war hier Jericho von Christoph und ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißt.
Das heißt, es war von langer Hand geplant.
Nee, was heißt von, nee, das war, das ist, wie sich das so gehört.
Karte des Spiels.
Genau, das ist, das ist, das war mit, das war, die haben, so, so, vor vier Jahren hat Spreblich mal bei einem Innenministerium angerufen, beim Familienministerium angerufen, wenn da mal eine Ursula von der Laienministerin wird, dann muss die so ein Gesetz, wir haben da so eine Software rumliegen. Nee, Quatsch. Wie sich das so gehört, ist das irgendwie.
Aber es gab diese Anfrage von Johnny da auch, bei dem, dass sie sich da auch mal bitte äußern wollte.
Ja, aber die Idee ist tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, das Gesetz ist am Donnerstag, also am Donnerstag durchs Kabinett geboxt worden und die Idee ist natürlich mal wieder Mittwoch um 18 Uhr entstanden oder so was. Also, wenige Stunden vorher.
Falls irgendjemand noch nicht weiß, worüber wir reden, was man uns so recht nicht vorstellen könnte, wir reden natürlich über das, wo das ganze Twitter-Verse von Nurso Shepard in der letzten Zeit, du hast keine Ahnung, du hast irgendwie zwei Wochen im dunklen Raum gesessen.
Ja, nicht ganz, ich weiß schon ungefähr, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ihr speziell da im Zusammenhang mit Spreeblick meint.
Na ja, Spreeblick hat dann noch so eine Aktion gestartet, nachdem diese Unterschriften da geleistet wurden von den ASPs. Ja, womit das Ganze ja so öffentlich vorab zelebriert wurde mit, ja, jetzt zensieren, wir sind alle dabei. Bis auf eigentlich so einige, weil ja auch bestimmte Provider offiziell ja jetzt gar nicht sozusagen gezwungen werden sollen. Was auch Quatsch wäre, weil es gibt ja so viele Provider, wenn die dann alle mit diesen Listen ausstatten würden, das kriegen die ja nie gesichert. Die sind ja dann null Komma nix geleakt.
Naja, ich geb denen so auch nur so drei Sekunden, oder? Bis diese Listen...
Och, naja, feine Ahnung.
Also wie sieht das Ganze aus jetzt erstmal noch mal vielleicht ein bisschen von vorne weg? Also es gibt Frau von der Leyen? Kann man sie noch fragen?
Du meinst, wir sollen die ganze Geschichte jetzt nochmal erzählen?
So notdürftig, oder? Wenigstens so notdürftig auseinanderdevidieren, weil ich glaube, da wird gerne viel verwechselt.
Ja, der Innenminister möchte ganz gerne alle unter seine Kontrolle kriegen, aber er hat sich mittlerweile seinen Ruf so versaut, dass er seine Kabinettskollegen vorschicken muss. Und da haben sie sich erinnert, dass man ja rigide Sicherheitsmaßnahmen am besten mit Kinderpornografie durchs Netz treibt. Und dann haben sie wieder die alten Hüte aus dem Schrank geholt, aus der Schublade und einen erzählt von Millionenindustrie, Kipo überall, 20 Prozent aller Internet-User sind pädophil und was nicht alles. Und da müsste ja mal was getan werden. Und was sie dann halt machen, ist Stoppschilder überall aufstellen. Das erinnert mich übrigens an ein altes, großartiges Titanic-Cover von, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie lange das her ist, aber es passt wunderbar. Da ist dann so ein Wald zu sehen, vor allem ein Baum. Das beweist schon, das ist eine Schlagzeile. Endlich Bonn, also damals war es ja noch Bonn, Bonn rettet den Wald. Waldsterben verboten. Genau, dieses Schild. Waldsterben verboten, das war schon so diese erste Verkehrsschild-Diplomatie, die sie da irgendwie gestartet haben. Und jetzt haben sie sich halt überlegt, Kinderpornografie könnte man ja wahrscheinlich auch dadurch stoppen, dass man halt überall Stoppschilder aufbaut.
Das ist aber wirklich, also das ist, aber ein Stoppschild ist wirklich falsch.
Es wird nichts gegen die Täter gemacht, es wird nichts für die Kinder gemacht, es wird nicht mal was gegen den Content getan.
Sondern nur gegen dich.
Sondern es wird nur so ein Vorhang davor gehängt, so bitte nicht hintergucken.
Könnte Kinderpornografie hinter sein. Ich glaube, es ist sogar noch alles viel perfider. Also der ganze Vorwurf, na ja, aber das, was ihr da macht, das funktioniert ja gar nicht. Das kann ja leicht umgangen werden.
Das wird natürlich verboten.
Das ist die Falle. Also wenn man da jetzt reinmarschiert und sagt, ja, aber den S-Sperren, was ihr da vor habt, das ist doch eh nutzlos.
Das ändern die ja irgendwann.
Ja, dann werden die dann so in vier Wochen, wenn so die Öffentlichkeit bereit ist, sozusagen das offizielle Echo, dann sich auch mal von der Regierung erzählen zu lassen, dann kommen die mit so, ja, wir haben das jetzt geprüft und wir haben ja festgestellt, das reicht ja gar nicht, also müssen wir ja noch ganz andere Maßnahmen machen.
Genau, dann kommen die richtigen Sperren.
Und dann geht's erst los.
Wenn zwei Jahre oder fünf Jahre dauert, ist ja egal, irgendwann geht's. Und dann werden auch noch andere Sachen gesperrt. Kinderporno interessiert ja eh keinen.
Jaja, das ist ja auch schon das Üble. Ich meine diese Listen, die Sperrlisten in den Ländern, wo es das gab, was war das? Dänemark, Australien und so, die sind ja dann auch teilweise bei Wikileaks aufgeschlagen, wo dann halt auch Wikileaks drin zu finden war. So mit dieser Argumentation, na ja, auch Seiten, die auf Seiten verlinken, müssen wir ja auch machen. Also im Prinzip ist es ein komplettes Mundtot machen. Ich meine, diese ganze Aktion ist einfach so offensichtlich Wahlkampf und Leer, dass ich das auch, ich muss sagen, ich kann das auch teilweise nicht ernst nehmen. Trotzdem ist es natürlich wichtig, dagegen aufzustehen. Und ihr habt ja vorhin so viel Pessimismus hier geäußert im Vorfeld. Ich weiß nicht, ob so viel Pessimismus wirklich angebracht ist. Ich denke schon, dass diese Politikerkaste über kurz oder lang sich schon mit dieser Netzöffentlichkeit auseinandersetzen muss.
Aber sie ist im Augenblick noch sehr klein.
Nein, sie ist sehr nachhaltig.
Es gibt im Augenblick noch keinerlei politische Organisation. Die Aufregung ist zwar groß, bei Twitter, in den Blogs und so weiter und so fort, aber wir haben ja keine Lobby in dem Sinne. Also es ist auf der einen Seite der CCC, der sicherlich Gutes leistet, aber der, glaube ich, sicher nicht als politische Partei oder als politische Kraft zieht. Und darüber hinaus gibt es ja nicht viel. Also Piratenpartei, die würde ich jetzt als viel zu klein und sie überhaupt ernst zu nehmen betrachten im Augenblick.
Ich denke nicht, dass es jetzt einer Parteienot tut. Das ist nicht das Ding, sondern spüren müssen es halt.
Über das kurze Land muss man das Parlament fürchten.
Die Abgeordneten. Ich meine, bewegen tut sich immer dann was, wenn die Leute Angst haben um ihren Job. Und die haben dann Angst um ihren Job, wenn sie spüren, dass sie nicht mehr gewählt werden. Aus ihrem lokalen Verbund heraus nicht unterstützt werden. Und das funktioniert halt am besten über die Abgeordneten. Ich meine, es ist interessant zu sehen, dass viele Online-Protest, das ist alles sehr plakativ. Das hat sicherlich eine gewisse Kraft, das in die Medien zu bringen, auch wenn die nach wie vor versagt. Weil ich finde, dass die Medien ihren Job an der Stelle auch überhaupt nicht mehr machen. Dass die solche Gesetzesprojekte so unkritisch begleiten und da eigentlich auch genau auf dieselbe Nummer mit Kinderpornos ist böse. Und da muss man ja was tun. Und dann diese ganzen Zeitungskommentare bei tagesschau.de war auch so ein ganz furchtbarer Kommentar. Wenn auch nur ein Kind damit gerettet wird, dann ist es ja schon gut.
Das ist komplett online.
Die Leute sollten einfach mal unsere Verfassung lesen, was da drin steht.
Wir bekommen jetzt, um es vielleicht nochmal zu sagen, wir bekommen eine Polizeibehörde, erstellt Listen, wo sie Webseiten draufschreibt, auf die niemand mehr draufsurfen darf. Geheime Listen, die nicht öffentlich überwacht werden. Es wird niemand darüber informiert, was auf diesen Listen draufsteht. Du als Webseitenbetreiber wirst nicht darüber informiert, wenn du auf der Liste draufschreibst. Du hast kein Recht zu erfahren, warum du draufstehst. Du hast keine Möglichkeit, außer wenn du klagst, wieder runterzukommen. Man redet gern mal von Zensur und man sagt, das ist Zensur in einer reinrassigen Form. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie noch viel schlimmer sein könnte.
Naja, ich glaube, es wird sich nicht halten lassen. Ich denke, dass diese Konstruktion, die sie sich da ausgedacht hat, die wird spätestens beim Verfassungsgericht wieder verpuffen. Das ist halt immer so anstrengend, dass es immer soweit erst kommen muss, dass man da das Verfassungsgericht bemühen muss.
Dass da eine Regierung kam, die sich mittlerweile regelmäßig am Verfassungsgericht aufschrammt, finde ich wirklich beeindruckend.
Ja, das ist echt ein übler Trend. Aber was mich an der Stelle wirklich mehr nervt, sind die Medien, die an der Stelle offensichtlich noch nicht genug gelitten haben. Von daher kann man ihnen einfach nicht genug Konkurrenz machen.
Weil es sie noch nicht erwischt. Wenn eine Zeitung morgen nicht mehr am Kiosk liegen würde, weil das BKA beschlossen hat, dass da was drinsteht, was uns nicht in den Kram passt und wir sagen, warum das steht, ich möchte nicht wissen, wie groß der Aufschrei wäre.
Du meinst, dass sie die größeren Zeitschriften sperren?
Nicht mal das kriegen die ja mit. Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Journalistenkontakte. Gab es da irgendeinen nennenswerten Widerstand in der Zeitung? Hab ich nicht gelesen. Sicherlich wird sich da irgendwo mal einer kritisch geäußert haben, aber dass sie sich einfach mal alle zusammengerauft haben und gesagt haben, so geht es nicht. Sie sind ja nicht mehr in der Lage, ihre eigenen Interessen zu verteidigen. Wie sollen sie denn dann, also dieses Ding mit vierte Macht und so, das ist durch. Also das findet meiner Meinung nach nicht statt.
Ich finde, wir leben da auch in einer ganz irgendwie, ich mache mir da seit ein paar Wochen meine Gedanken so drüber, wir leben da in einer ganz spannenden Zeit eigentlich.
Mögest du in interessanten Zeiten leben?
Na ja, das tun wir alle irgendwie.
Findest du den Satz nicht? Das ist ein chinesischer Fluch.
Danke.
Ja, in China wird das sozusagen alles, was unangenehm ist, angesehen.
Na ja, die wissen schon warum. Aber auf der einen Seite, wir haben in letzter Zeit, in den letzten Jahren, so viele neue Freiheiten bekommen durch das Netz, dass jetzt, ich glaube, wahrscheinlich hat die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung schon immer Angst gehabt vor zu viel Freiheiten. Man sagt zwar immer Freiheit und je und wir sind alle für Freiheit, aber Freiheit heißt ja immer nur...
Freiheit war ja hier sogar pro Relia in diesem Wochenende angeblich. Also mit diesem Freiheit-Ding, das ist schon ganz schön verpufft, nicht wahr? Zumal auch so dieses Primat des Wortes Sicherheit und Beschützen und so. Also das scheint irgendwie so ein bisschen das Problem zu sein, dass die Gesellschaft auf einmal glaubt, dass es die Aufgabe des Staates wäre, die Bürger zu beschützen und dass der Staat die Bürger vor irgendwas beschützen muss. Das ist irgendwie so drin in den Köpfen. Es ist immer bedrohliche Ängste gibt da draußen, vor denen die beschützt werden müssen. Das ist aber nicht das, was in der Verfassung steht.
Na das zum einen, was mir vorhin erst aufgefallen ist, wo so zwei Generationen aneinander vorbei reden. Ich hab in letzter Zeit viel diskutiert über diesen Begriff Digital Native, mit dem ich massive Bauchschmerzen habe und der mir immer nicht in Kram passt. Aber ich glaube, was wirklich ein interessantes Phänomen ist, es gibt Leute in diesem Land, für die ist das Internet ein Medium. Und es gibt Leute wie uns, für die ist das Internet das Leben. Also wir kommunizieren, wir haben Freundschaften übers Netz. Während andere Leute lesen Spiegel online und die gucken sich vielleicht hin und wieder mal ein YouTube-Video an. Und für die ist das ein reines Konsum-Medium. Und dementsprechend wollen sie es auch kontrolliert haben. Also da wollen sie das Jugendschutz-Gesetz durchgedrückt werden. Und da wollen sie keinen Schweinkram sehen. Und da wollen sie das und das nicht sehen. Weil das sind wir auch aus dem Fernsehen so gewohnt. Wir wollen ja auch auf meinen Büchern, wenn da mal ein Timmel zu sehen ist, dann muss der ja auch unter einen Laden teken. Und das ist, dass das alles gut ist. Wohingegen für uns als Lebensmedium, wir gehen daran, dass wir wahrscheinlich mit dem Gedanken, wenn ich auf der Straße stehe, dann möchte ich auch nicht bis 22 Uhr warten müssen, bis ich mit meinen Freunden über Pornografie reden darf oder über die Themen, die mich interessieren. Und darum nehmen wir das wahrscheinlich viel stärker als Eingriff in unsere Freiheitsrechte wahr, als irgendjemand, der das Internet, den du wieder mal nutzt, um mal bei Ebay eine Bestellung abzuschicken. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist, auch für solche Menschen sollte Zensur von einem Medium oder von so einem wichtigen Medium, den im Internet, sollte ein Problem darstellen. Und das tut es aus irgendeinem Grund für niemand. Ich finde das wirklich erschreckend.
Na, eine Zensur findet nicht statt.
Na, wenn es da steht, dann wird es wohl wahr sein.
Ja, das ist so die Wahrnehmung. Ich meine, wir sind auch glaube ich immer noch in so ein bisschen... Also die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, einschließlich des Ostens, lebt immer noch in so einem Märchenland. Also wir glauben immer noch, dass wir vollkommen davor gefeit sind, dass die Gründe, aus denen die Verfassung dieses Landes mal so gemacht wurde, wie sie gemacht wurde, dass das nicht mehr zutrifft. Dass wir sozusagen immun sind bei Definition. Damit meine ich gar nicht so sehr, nur die Nazis kommen wieder. Dagegen, speziell gibt es halt schon einen organisierten Widerstand, der vielleicht auch hier und da zu spät, aber dann doch schon immer noch greift. Nur so dieses grundsätzliche Verstehen von dem Freiheitkonstrukt, insbesondere der Freiheit der Kommunikation, Meinungsäußerungen und so weiter. Das ist halt, was das Internet betrifft, noch nicht verstanden, weil das Internet noch nicht verstanden ist. Dieses Mit-Wir-Leben im Internet, das ist ja auch überspitzen. Das kannst du so auch keinem erklären. Du kannst keinem sagen, ich lebe ja im Internet. Ach so wirklich? Ich wohne in Prenzlauer Berg. So funktioniert das nicht. Sondern was man klar machen muss, ist, dass es jetzt ein Universal-Medium gibt. Das Internet ist ein universeller Kanal zum Transport von allem. Und weil das so ist, ist es ein besonders schützenswertes Gut, wie eben auch unser öffentlicher Raum ein besonders schützenswertes Gut ist. Aber wenn du natürlich über Videokameraüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum diskutierst, dann musst du natürlich auch über die Videokameras im Internet reden. Das ist an der Stelle dieselbe Diskussion. Wenn auch das Internet so noch gar nicht als öffentlicher Raum erkannt wird. Das tun natürlich einige. Und ich glaube, dass die Zahl derer, die das so sehen, massiv steigt. Einfach dadurch, dass jedes Jahr kommt wieder irgendeine Geburtswelle dazu, für die das vollkommen normal ist. Und die auch wissen, was sie alle schon getan haben im Internet.
Ach, ich weiß nicht. Also ich hab immer... Ich finde übrigens, der Vergleich mit der DDR ist da gar nicht so schlecht. Weil in der DDR war es ja... Eine Zensur fand ja auch in der DDR nicht statt. Und es gab auch da kein Zensurministerium und dergleichen und so fort. Und trotzdem weiß natürlich jeder, dass man in der DDR nicht sagen durfte, was man dachte. Und das funktionierte in erster Linie natürlich auf solchen Subtilen. Es gab so einen gesellschaftlichen Kodex quasi, was man in der Öffentlichkeit, also auch ich damals als Schüler, wusste natürlich selbstverständlich, was in der Schule erzählen darf und was nicht. Und ich finde jetzt mit dieser Internet-Zensur, es ist ja explizit erwähnt, man landet ja automatisch in einer Überwachung. Wenn man auf diesen Stoppseiten landet, dann ist man ja, dann hat man ja quasi, da könnte drunter stehen, das BKA hat sich notiert, dass sie hier waren. Und wann das dann eingreift und so, da soll sich niemand Sorgen machen. Wir suchen nur die raus. Aber man steht, man wird überwacht, sobald man auf bestimmten andrückigen Seiten drauf ist. Und das wird natürlich das Surferhalten ändern. Ich glaube, da braucht sich niemand Gedanken drüber zu machen. Also, dass Webseiten wie WikiLeaks da mit draufstehen werden, ich glaube, das braucht niemand zu bezweifeln.
Ja, na gut, wie gesagt, ich denke, das wird sich alles nicht halten lassen. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich jetzt so absurd. Also Leute sozusagen auch dafür schon zu verdächtigen, dass sie auf diesen Stoppseiten landen, das wird nicht lange dauern, bis der halbe Bundestag da mal drauf rumgeklickt hat, weil ihnen irgendjemand...
Wie lange hat Aktion Himmel, wie viele Leute sind da, wie viele Wohnungsunterricht durchsucht worden? 12.000? Wegen irgendwelchen Zahlen.
Das ist jetzt ein Beispiel.
Das ist ein Beispiel dafür, das ist...
Das ist plakatives Blabla.
Genau, da werden 12.000 Ermittlungsverfahren eingeladen. So und so viele tausend Wohnungen werden durchsucht. Es ist bisher noch nicht zu einer Verurteilung gekommen. Trotzdem wird das als erfolgreiche Aktion verkauft.
Natürlich wird es das.
Es sagt auch niemand, was dagegen ist.
Wir reden jetzt über ein Gesetz. Dieses Gesetz muss Bestand haben, spätestens bis zum Verfassungsgericht.
Das Verfassungsgericht wird dann irgendwann...
Das wird es aber nicht tun. Weil es einfach nicht geht. Solange wir noch ein Verfassungsgericht haben, was in etwa kongruent ist mit dem, was in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren geurteilt hat, da geht einfach nichts. Da bin ich eigentlich relativ zuversichtlich. Es ist natürlich ein bisschen schade, immer aufs Verfassungsgericht zu vertrauen an der Stelle. Aber ich denke, dass man eben auch mit diesem Selbstbewusstsein in diese Diskussion gehen sollte. Und da einfach sehr aufrecht diesen Leuten widersprechen soll.
Was kommt dann, wenn das Verfassungsgericht sagt, dass man das Verfassungsgericht, das wollen wir so nicht?
Na, was weiß ich, was dann als nächstes kommt.
Dann wird das Gesetz nachgebessert.
Das ist ein fortschreitender Kampf. Es ist nicht so, dass die Welt jetzt morgen untergeht. Das ist jetzt irgendwie alles total bekloppt und scheiße. Und es stinkt und es ist widerlich und es ist Wahlkampf. Und das wissen wir auch alle. Und keiner will mehr irgendjemand wählen. Und ich glaube halt, dass das schon seine Auswirkungen hat. Ich kann jetzt hier nicht den Visionär spielen, der jetzt irgendwie die nächsten Wahlergebnisse voraussagt. Oder die Piratenpartei kriegt irgendwie zehn Prozent. Ich glaube auch, dass die Piratenpartei da keine Hilfe ist. An der Stelle, weil das wählt eh keiner. Jaja, klar. Das ist nicht so der Punkt. Aber man muss, das Internet muss lernen, seine Forderungen durchzusetzen. Das ist eigentlich das, was ich sagen will. Derzeit haben wir uns da noch nicht gefunden. Weil einfach auch der Schmerz noch nicht so groß ist wie der Spaß. Wir genießen schon noch unsere Freiheiten. Jetzt gibt es so einen Schimmer am Horizont, wo irgendwie jeder sieht, die Sonne ein bisschen untergehen. Jetzt wird es wärmer.
Das ist ja schon eine Weile länger, dass die Einschränkungen näher kommen.
Ja, wie auch immer. Dieses Gefühl wird zunehmen. Mehr Leute werden das Internet verstehen. Ich glaube daran, dass diese Mobilisierung über das Netz stattfinden wird. Sie muss jetzt erst noch mal kommen.
Wir müssen sie auch vorantreiben.
Wir sind dabei. Jetzt reden wir sogar in einem Macintosh-Podcast über Zensur in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. So weit ist es schon gekommen. Und das, obwohl wir hier eigentlich die erklärte Spaßfraktion sind, von der jeder weiß, Macintosh-Leute sind nur an Konsum interessiert, haben keine Ahnung von Technik, haben zu viel Geld, zu viel Zeit, trinken den ganzen Tag nur Milchkaffee und? Warte und spiel einen Lothrunner. Ja, so.
Künstlerpack halt.
Genau, und wollen wir uns jetzt wieder ablenken von den bösen Nachrichten?
Na gut, lönnen wir uns mal ein bisschen davon ab und denken uns jetzt weiter dazu.
Und einfach jetzt wieder über unsere schöne Konsumwelt reden? Ja, die Unzensierte. Dass es einfach keine Zensur gibt, weil keiner wird meinen Amazon-Link wegzensieren. Denn wenn ich kaufe, bin ich ein guter Bürger.
Na da, bin ich mal gespannt. Hast du mal geguckt, was wenn man Netzwerk aus... Was war das? Netzwerkkabel? Netzwerkverkabelung bei Amazon?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was bei Amazon los war, aber man konnte da irgendwas, PC-Netzwerke oder so was, PC vernetzen.
Genau, das...
Und mit Sachbuch ging's irgendwie auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch geht und ich hab auch überhaupt keine Ahnung, warum. Ich hab das nur in irgendeinem Blog-Eintrag gelesen. Das ausprobiert, dachte ich, fall vom Stuhl. Also man gibt bei amazon.de, ich probier's jetzt noch mal ein, man gibt irgendwie ein...
Ich glaube Netzwerkkabel.
Ich mag vielleicht alles funktionieren, ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ich hab PC-Vernetzen eingegeben. PC-Vernetzen. So, und das gibt man dann jetzt ein. Und das Internet ist langsam. Geht nicht mehr.
PC-Vernetzung.
Tatsache, jetzt kommt wirklich Sachen...
Kommt keine Analmassage mehr, wenn man PC-Vernetzung eingibt.
Es kam nur so irgendwie Gay-Literatur. Total krass. Ich weiß auch nicht, irgendwas ist ihnen da glaube ich im Index kaputt gegangen. Ob das damit zu tun hat, dass irgendwie vorher in dem amerikanischen Amazon-Store dieser komische Effekt auftrat, dass du die alle nicht mehr gefunden hast? Haben die die sozusagen aus dem amerikanischen Index rausgenommen und die deutschen anfangs dadurch ersetzt? Das war schon fast mein Eindruck.
Alles, was in Amerika verboten ist, wird automatisch nur noch in Deutschland verkauft.
Wer jetzt hier zugestoßen ist in den letzten Minuten, vielleicht noch mal hinweisen. Es gibt ja auch noch den Chat. Wir sind immer noch im IRC, irc.freenote.net/mobilemax. Das ist unser Kanal, da wird ordentlich diskutiert und links gepostet und was nicht alles. Nur mal so ganz nebenbei. Wir können dich immer mitlesen, aber...
Onlineieren für Profis.
Wir haben... Du liest jetzt im Chat. Du musst jetzt sagen, dass du das sekundär quälend zitiert hast.
Achso, das ist jetzt nicht das nächste Thema.
Ja genau. Was ist denn das nächste Thema? Dennis baut Hardware. Dennis. Hä? Du hast jetzt gesagt, du hast jetzt von Lothron die Schnauze voll. Und Desktop Tower Defense zieht dich auch nur noch in den Mittagspausen. Und du machst jetzt auch keine Software mehr, sondern wirst jetzt irgendwie...
Na ich hab schon seit, keine Ahnung, mehreren Wochen, zwei Monaten oder so, bin ich irgendwie auch so ein bisschen auf der Hardware-Phase, weil ich ja auch mein Fernseher reparieren musste. Da musste man ja auch mal mit einem Lötkolben schwingen und mit einem Multimeter ran und so. Und seitdem bin ich halt voll in einer Bastelfase. Und jetzt gerade... Du willst jetzt über Uhren reden?
Nö, sollst du einfach nur mal erzählen, was du da machst?
Na ich baue mir gerade eine DCF-Uhr, die ist eigentlich auch schon fertig, bis auf das jetzt gerade das Antennenkabel schon wieder ab ist. Und deswegen konnte ich die gerade nicht vorführen. Aber sie funktioniert und sie zeigt die Uhrzeit an. Und zwar über Funksignale, also ich muss die nicht stellen.
Woran erkennt man einen Nerd, dass er Sätze anfängt, mit die ist eigentlich schon fertig, aber...
Die ist fertig.
Auf jeden Fall blinkt sie schick.
Die ist voll toll.
Hol doch mal. Ich meine, da hinten funktioniert sie nicht, hier funktioniert sie nicht, aber sie kann auf jeden Fall schön die Zeit durchdickern.
Und ich geh demnächst in Massenproduktion. Und dann geht China pleite, weil ich unterbiete die.
Auf jeden Fall hast du dich total abgelenkt und kannst irgendwie die ganzen neuen Konsumfreuden überhaupt nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen. Dabei kann man jetzt Filme kaufen und Filme leihen im iTunes Store.
Hast du das nicht?
Hast du das schon probiert? Ich habe das noch nicht getan. Ich habe lediglich Zeit damit verbracht, um zu gucken, ob irgendwelche Filme da werden.
Das ging aber vorher auch schon. Du meinst jetzt HD-Movies?
Nein, Leihen. Was kostet denn der Spaß?
In dem Sinne gab es ein sehr geringes Angebot. Jetzt gibt es halt so ein richtiges...
Also die Serien gab es ja schon vorher.
Ja, Serien. Aber jetzt gibt es Filme, also so Hollywood. Wie gesagt, ich habe nur mit dem Mausfinger über den Button gehowert, weil ich wusste, dass ich eh keine Zeit haben werde, mir die anzuschauen.
Aber darum geht es doch nicht, Mann.
Ja, danach habe ich auch gesucht, ob es irgendwas gibt, was ich trotzdem kaufen würde, sozusagen just for the fun of it. Oder weil es mir irgendwie so viel Wert ist oder so in meinem Herzen liegt, aber da war mir dann das Angebot dann doch zu bekloppt.
Das gab es dann alles.
Ach, frag mich. Sachen, die ich nicht kannte. Und so Filme...
Mainstream Shit, den man sowieso schon gesehen hat. Oder wo man schon weiß, dass man ihn nicht sehen will.
Ja, genau. So grinsende Couples irgendwie mit Boy meets Girl. Tra la la. Eine bezaubernde Romance. Generische Titel, die ich...
Umgänge, da wird sowas als Chick Flick bezeichnet.
Was ist das?
Filme für Mädchen.
Aber es gibt High School Musical 3. Das ist für kleine Teenager. Das kenne ich nur aus South Park.
Ganz bestimmt ein Chick Flick.
Nee, das ist nur für Teenager.
Wobei ja gerade, ich meine, wir sind ja der Apple Podcast-Dingens. Wir sind der Apple Podcast-Dingens. Der Icon Storm mit seinem Musikangebot, da haben viele gesagt, das ist ja eigentlich eine Chance auch für die Independent Labels, da ihr Zeug ohne groß Arbeit da reinzubringen und auch irgendwie bekannt zu werden und gleich eine Vertriebsplattform zu haben, ohne dass man sich gleich so einem riesigen Musikunternehmen unterwerfen muss. Und das Gleiche gilt doch aber eigentlich auch für Independent Movies jetzt, oder nicht? Aber die gibt es da leider noch nicht, anscheinend.
Nee, Independent Movies gibt es da irgendwie nicht.
Weil das wär's ja eigentlich als Vertriebsplattform. Ich meine, so ein Movie ist ja auch irgendwie...
Ja, einen Vertrieb brauchst du ja wahrscheinlich auch weiterhin. Du brauchst halt nicht mehr...
Na guck mal, die kleinen Filme, die kommen halt schwer ans Kino, weil die Kinos wollen halt nicht so, weil dann ist immer leer und du musst halt auch die Filmrollen machen und das kostet alles Geld. Und ich meine, bei so einem iTunes-Filmverleih, da ist es ja viel leichter irgendwie. Und vielleicht kommt er dann dadurch, weil er da so bekannt wurde, vielleicht dann doch sogar noch in die Kinos. Aber ich denke mal, die Entwicklung dauert noch ein bisschen. Aber ich könnte mir das gut vorstellen.
Ja, passieren wird das hoffentlich. Also passieren wird das über kurzer lang bestimmt. Das ist auch kleinere dadurch eine Chance. Vor allen Dingen, so die Videothek der Zukunft hat theoretisch eines Tages die Chance, wirklich mal eine richtig schöne große Auswahl zu haben, wie sie am Augenblick nur so kleine Spezialitäten-Videotheken haben. Und nicht mehr nur den ganzen Mainstream-Scheiß.
Klar, wird halt so kommen wie mit dem Audio.
Casablanca zum Beispiel. Casablanca könnte man sich doch gut mal angucken. Der ist laut iTunes vom 15.
Februar 2000. Und der kostet jetzt 8 Euro und dann hast du ihn gekauft.
Genau. Und für 3 Euro kann ich ihn leihen.
Und für 4 Euro kriegst du die Reste DVD in der Videothek.
Videothek? Ja, aber Videothek ist einfach mal vorbei.
Da muss man schon ein bisschen verleiden, dass man nicht das Haus verlassen will.
Also es sieht schon nicht so gut aus für die in den nächsten 10 Jahren, würde ich mal behaupten, aber es dauert schon noch ein bisschen. Aber ich finde, die Preise sind auch noch alle ein bisschen sehr hoch.
Für diese ganzen Videotheken, ja das ist echt alles zu teuer.
Nee, hier Filme kaufen digital. Das ist halt wie mit dem...
Also ich finde, das Angebot ist eigentlich schon völlig in Ordnung. 4 Euro kostet das? Ja, ja, der war kurz abgerissen, ich bin hier gerade dabei irgendwie. Ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was ist hier gerade verreckt.
Reconnect.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Reconnect ist. Ich glaube, das war eher so eine Verpeilung, weil ihr haltet Netz und ich hatte hier irgendwie kein Netz, aber ich hatte auch irgendwie meinen VPN an und das war wahrscheinlich wieder so ein Fehler. Ja, es tut mir ja so leid. Ich arbeite auch daran, dass das besser wird, aber derzeit ist irgendwie gerade alles ein bisschen bekloppt.
Also 3 Euro, um Casablanca mir auszuleihen, finde ich dann doch ein bisschen teuer, ehrlich zu sein.
Naja, wieso? Weil du das schon kennst?
Nee, ich hab den noch nie gesehen. Also ich glaube, ich werde mir das mal geben, einfach um es mal ausprobieren zu haben.
Bloß Klick? Nee, nicht jetzt.
Nee, nicht jetzt, wir müssen noch... Leercake ist ganz hübsch. Sind die dann auf Deutsch oder Englisch?
Ich hab gehört, hab ich bei Leo gelesen, dass da ihnen so ein bisschen was kaputt gegangen ist.
Dass er irgendwie Englisch steht, aber es doch in Deutsch ist und so weiter.
Genau, der ist ja nur in Deutsch, will ich gar nicht.
Aber wenn zwei Sprachen dabei sind, ist es auf jeden Fall richtig, aber vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile auch gefixt.
Hoffentlich. Hab ich auch mal irgendwann zur Hälfte gesehen. Deutsch und Englisch, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Ja, mir ist das auf jeden Fall auch noch nicht genug Suchmöglichkeit. Also das ist ja auch alles nicht so richtig sophisticated. Aber mal gucken. Das Angebot scheint auf jeden Fall sehr übersichtlich zu sein.
Was sind zwei Seiten, wenn ich das richtig sehe, kann das sein? Ach so, neu zum Line.
Na, wenn man ja hier alle anzeigen zum Line, dann ja zwei Seiten, das ist natürlich nichts. Hat sich echt noch nicht viel getan.
Na ja, das muss sich jetzt ja erstmal noch ein bisschen entwickeln und größer werden und dann irgendwann ist es auch voll wie so eine riesengroße Bibliothek. Und die nehmen ja nichts raus, also hoffe ich mal.
Na, ich probier das mal bei Gelegenheit. Wäre natürlich clever gewesen, das ich schon vorher ausprobiert gehabt habe.
Ja, aber was soll denn das? Ich meine, es gibt hier Star Trek... Star Trek 6 und Star Trek 7. Ja, aber Star Trek 1 bis 5... Gibt's nicht... .ist nicht dabei.
Es gibt ja auch den Urknaller, leg dich nicht mit Zuhahn an. Der ist bestimmt auch...
Ich meine, das sagt doch alles aus. Das ist wirklich schlecht. Ich frage mich, ich meine, wie können sie nur auf die Idee kommen, mit so wenig Filmen zu starten?
Oder?
Naja, besser als gar nicht.
Ich glaube, da wäre es besser gewesen, gar nicht zu starten.
Wahrscheinlich mussten sie den Vertriebsfirmen erst mal zeigen, dass es irgendwie funktioniert, und die haben dafür halt mal so ein paar Filme so rausgerückt.
Ja, aber dass das funktioniert, das wissen wir nun mittlerweile.
Ja, oder Terminate hat...
Ja, wir wissen das, die Vertriebsfirmen wissen das nicht. Vor allem haben die voll Angst, dass ihnen so wie bei der Musik, dass sie wieder ihre eigene Plattform nicht an den Start kriegen. Also...
Three Kings ist ganz okay, den kann man sich mal gucken.
Ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, weil einfach kein Film dabei war, der mir jetzt irgendwie...
Und HD ist nur auf dem Apple TV?
Nee, und auf dem iTunes selber.
Aber auch verfügbar in HD auf Apple TV?
Soweit ich weiß, geht das hier auch im iTunes.
Aber dann muss man immer noch mal hinzufügen, dass wenn man jetzt so einen Film runterlädt und man hat in fünf Jahren Willman, irgendwie findet man den Mac plötzlich blöde, weil die PCs jetzt mal voll cool geworden sind. Also nur mal rein theoretisch, ja. Also ganz theoretisch. Dann kann man die dann nicht mehr gucken, richtig? Doch, weil dann gibt's auch einen iTunes. Okay, aber man ist schon auf... Man ist immer auf den iTunes angewiesen.
Man ist schon auf den iTunes angewiesen.
Und wenn man seine Rechner wechselt, dann ist man auf den Apple angewiesen, weil man umsubscribe muss. Und weil's Apple dann mal nicht mehr geben sollte, kann man irgendwie seine Movies nicht mit rüberziehen. Das heißt, man kann irgendwie seine Riesenfilmsammlung so nicht mal an seine Kinder vererben später.
Kaufen finde ich völlig uninteressant. Also das einzige, was ich interessant finde, ist Linen.
Nur kurz gucken und rein in die Rübe und...
Ja, ich mein, wie häufig guckst du Filme?
Also ich besitze ehrlich gesagt mehr DVD-Player als DVDs. Das ist wirklich kein Witz.
Bei mir ist es noch nicht ganz so schlimm. Aber mal ehrlich, Musik hört man häufig.
Aber einen Film guckt man einmal.
Genau aus dem Grund.
Einmal und dann gibt es ein paar Filme, die kauft man mehrmals und da kauf ich mir auch eine DVD.
Die leitet man mehrmals, meinst du?
Nö, die, naja, keine Ahnung.
Du hast gerade gesagt, die kauft man mehrmals.
Hab ich das gesagt.
Die schaut man mehrfach.
Die kauft man sich und schaut sie sich mehrmals an. Beziehungsweise kauft man sich so eine Special Edition. Also zum Beispiel meinen Lieblingsfilm.
Brasil.
Brasil, genau. Hab ich in der sogenannten Criterion Edition. Das ist so ein dickes 3D-VD-starkes Pack. Und das ist Mehrwert. Also das ist wirklich Mehrwert in jeder Hinsicht. Weil du hast ja erstmal alle Fassungen des Films und so. Und dann hast du eben auch eine Version, wo der Regisseur den Film drunterquatscht. Sehr interessant. Und sowas finde ich irgendwie prima.
Ja, hab ja mal geguckt, Brasil gibt es ja immer noch nicht bei Pirate Bay als Blu-Ray.
Was? Gibt es nicht? Wahrscheinlich gibt es keine Blu-Ray-Version.
Also bei Pirate Bay findet man es ganz schön drauf.
Ich glaube bei dem Film, da würde es auch nicht sehr viel bringen.
Wieso?
Naja, weil das Original nicht die Qualität hat.
Die bringen jeden Scheit als Blu-Ray raus.
Klar. Und schon alleine mit so einem Kinofilm.
Also so ein Kinofilm hat schon nochmal reichlich mehr Qualität als so eine DVD. Also eine DVD ist echt so das unterste an Qualität, was ich noch so gucke. Also das Internet, gerade auch dieses Pirate Pay, also ich meine, das ist illegal und wie die da auch immer alles sehen. Aber die Qualität, die die damit erzeugen, also den Qualitätsanspruch, den die bei mir erzeugen, der ist extrem hoch. Und da können die mit so einer DVD, holen die mich echt nicht mehr aus dem Bett raus morgens, mittags, nachmittags, abends.
Nachts.
Überhaupt so.
Hier kommst du eh nicht mehr aus dem Bett. Kann ich mal hier nebenbei erzählen?
Wo wir gerade beim Shoppen sind. Ich hab mal bei Amazon Musik gekauft. Das geht ja jetzt auch.
Amazon MP3. Da kauft man dann echte MP3s?
Ohne DRM. Mit deinem Namen signiert?
Bitte?
Mit deinem Namen signiert.
Gute Frage, hab ich noch gar nicht geguckt. Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass dem so ist.
Also bei Apple ist es ja so, da gibt's ja auch ohne DRM, aber da ist ja trotzdem die User-Credentials irgendwie eingebrannt.
Ja, weiß ich gar nicht. Müsste man mal gucken.
Und wie ist das so? Wie kauft sich's bei Amazon ein?
Ach naja, man muss halt so ein Programm runterladen, so ein MP3-Downloader.
Na, den gibt's aber schon seit jetzt zwei Jahren fast oder so, oder? Ich mein, das gibt's doch schon ewig. Diesen MP3-Downloader.
Na ja, das ist ja alles nichts Neues in dem Sinne, dass das ja in den USA schon eine Weile so läuft.
Aber ich hatte den noch bei mir auch schon mal drauf irgendwann.
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall brauchst du den, weil wenn du das kaufst, kaufst du halt so ein, ich glaube, Punkt-A- und Z-File, was sozusagen wie so ein Torrent funktioniert, wo sozusagen der Purchase drin ist und dann wird damit das Downloader-Tool instruiert und autorisiert, die eigentlichen Dateien, die du gekauft hast, dann runterzuziehen.
Aber er lädt dann auch alle, wenn du ein Album kaufst, alle auf einmal runter?
Ja, ja. Das geht auch relativ fix. Und dann liegen die dann halt auf deiner Platte rum und dann editet er sie aber auch gleich in die iTunes-Library, was dann zuführt, dass du dann auch gleich zweimal auf der Platte hast, je nachdem, wie so dein iTunes konfiguriert ist. Und dann hast du das. Die Experience ist so generell so ein bisschen bekloppt, wenn man so einen Flashblocker dran hat, dann fehlt irgendwie dieser Flashplayer, der dann auf diesen Preview-Click reagiert und das abspielt und stattdessen lädt dann dein Safari einen MP3-Stream-Link runter. So nach dem Motto, wenn er das Widget nicht erreichen kann, dann zumindest probiert das so. Und je nachdem, wie dein Safari eingestellt ist, wird das mehr oder weniger sofort in den iTunes-Genhof.
Man muss den Flashblocker deaktivieren bei Amazon einfach für die Mail.
Du musst vorher diesen Player anklicken, damit der schon mal läuft. Ja gut, aber das zeigt natürlich auch, wie fragil diese ganze Web-Experience ist, weil sie halt sehr davon abhängt, dass dein Browser schon in einer bestimmten Konfiguration ist.
Ja, aber ich finde dieses iTunes-Zum-Einkaufen von Musik, finde ich dann doch lieber ein MP3. Ich meine, wenn ich meinen Flashblocker einrichte, dann weiß ich, wie ich den Flashblocker auch wieder abschalten kann für die eine Webseite. Das finde ich echt...
Ja, du musst ja erstmal schnallen, dass es daran liegt, weil das ist so ein kleines Fitzel-Teil.
Ja, okay, aber...
Wie auch immer, natürlich magst du das so tun. Nur, ich sag ja, es ist eine fragile Konstruktion, die darauf basiert, die eine bestimmte Annahme davon macht, wie dein Client ausgerüstet ist, und das muss nicht zwangsläufig so sein. Also, es geht so, es ist billiger. Ich hab dann auch mal so ein paar Alben verglichen, wo man halt beim iTunes, bei manchen Sachen, eben nur das ganze Album kaufen kann, um einen bestimmten Track zu kriegen, wird der Track teilweise bei Amazon Einzelnen noch angeboten, wo du, dann hab ich so ein paar Sachen gefunden, so ein Album, was nur sieben Tracks enthält, und du kannst jeden Track kaufen für einen Euro.
Und das gesamte Album kostet zehn.
Das ganze Album kostet zehn, genau. Aber du kannst halt nicht alle Tracks kaufen, sondern eben zwei nicht.
Ach so, also Bonus-Tracks mäßig.
Genau, na nicht Bonus-Tracks, sondern als...
Die es nur der Nur-Album-Variante gibt.
Ja, das sind so die, ja genau, weil die entweder besonders lang sind, oder weil sie die einfach weggelassen haben, damit es noch einen Grund gibt, den ganzen Preis.
Alles über sieben Minuten kann man nur, glaube ich, kaufen, wenn man das ganze Album kauft.
So und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass bei Amazon das ein bisschen anders ist. Also erstens kannst du da, zumindest soweit ich das festgestellt habe, immer alle Tricks einzeln kaufen. Das ist also, das gibt es nur mit, wobei ich mir nicht ganz so sicher bin, mit so richtig langen Sachen. Aber auf jeden Fall bei diesem Album mit sieben Tricks war dann halt auch, der Albumpreis lag dann bei sieben Euro. Also es war dann billiger.
Und von daher, ich finde ja diese Pseudo-Abzocke auch immer ein bisschen nervig.
Also man kann bei Amazon Geld sparen, aber nicht unbedingt immer. Es ist aber auch so, dass das Angebot bei Amazon schlechter war. Also ich habe so ein paar Sachen gesucht und da gab es dann einfach besseres Zeug. Aber das mag jetzt meiner Suche geschuldet sein.
Aber langsam kommt es doch mal in Fahrt, dass man eine gewisse Auswahl hat, wenn man Musik kaufen will. Man kann bei iTunes kaufen.
Ja, aber ich kaufe echt lieber mit iTunes, muss ich sagen. Also das war jetzt irgendwie nicht so die Experience, die ich gerne mal machen würde.
Also ich glaube, ich probiere das nochmal aus. Ich teste das einfach mal und gucke, was bei rauskommt.
Und würdest du auch Musik mit dir kaufen oder nur ohne?
Nö, ohne. Naja, ich habe früher mal so einzelne Tracks, die ich jetzt unbedingt brauchte, schnell, die habe ich mal so gekauft und mir dann auch gleich irgendwie de, weiß schon, gebrannt und auf andere Art und Weise nicht DRM-falls umgewandelt.
Verstehe.
Aber dass ich jetzt auch mal wirklich sage, so zack, jetzt kaufe ich mich ja eine fure Kinderlieder oder sowas, dafür ist irgendwie iTunes einfach prima. One Stop. Man verbraucht halt nicht so viel Zeit. Naja, das war so mein Ausflug in die Amazon-Welt. Ansonsten ist es eigentlich besser zum Bücher kaufen. Tja, aber warum Apple TV nicht billiger geworden ist, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Stimmt. Das müsste ja eigentlich, eigentlich war ja der Gedanke, dass Apple TV billiger machen und wahrscheinlich war das, weil die Auswahl an Filmen so grottig ist, dass sie wissen, dass niemand, deswegen.
Naja, Henne Ei. Also das, das Ding müssen sie eigentlich noch ein bisschen billiger bauen oder zumindest ein bisschen billiger verschabeln. Aber vielleicht haben sie hier nicht genug Mut.
Ah, der war hier noch immer ein bisschen teurer, weil es hier nicht durch den Filmdownload gesponsert werden konnte. Richtig, so war es ja in der Mitte.
Sie haben in den USA den Preis gesenkt, nachdem sie rente.
Vielleicht kommt das ja hier noch.
Naja, aber das war halt zeitgleich.
Ja, okay, aber...
Ja klar, vielleicht kommt es noch, aber...
Vielleicht können wir die sicher nicht ganz so just in time wie da drüben.
Bis, bisher ist es nicht gekommen.
Ich hab ja beim letzten Mal, wo wir gerade beim Thema Einkaufen sind, jetzt kommt mal wieder eine schlechte Überleitung, darüber gejammert, dass es nichts gibt auf dem Mac, mit dem man sich seinen Kontoauszug anzeigen lassen kann. Und dann ist mir ja Saldo Mart ans Herz gelegt worden.
Das haben wir über Bank X geredet und so was.
Da haben wir über Bank X geredet. Und ich hab mir jetzt Saldo Mart gekauft. Das kann einem in der Menüleiste, neben der Uhr quasi, anzeigen, wie man Geld auf dem Konto hat.
Meinst du das auf dem Mac, nicht auf dem iPhone?
Auf dem Mac.
Du hast jetzt da, zeig mal, 15.000 Euro Miese.
Seitdem ich Opel gekauft habe, tut mir leid.
Wo steht das?
Da, das sind keine 15.000 Miese. Die Zahl hat sich der Dennis gerade ausgedacht.
20.000 Euro Miese.
Aber ich hab plötzlich das Gefühl, als ob ich auch noch mal die Chance hätte, mit Geld umgehen zu lernen. Weil bisher kannte ich in meinem Zustand Konto voll.
Und kriegst du dann auch so ein...
Konto leer.
Wie heißt die? Dieses Programm, was immer so hochpopft von allein, das ist das Framework.
Growl.
Genau, kriegst du auch so Growl-Meldungen. Zack, da hat einer irgendwie dich gefischt und abgehoben.
Er zeigt so Eingänge an, also kleine grüne Eikens an, neben dem Konto-Stand. Und Abbuchungen sind in rot. Dann kann man draufklicken. Und dann sieht man aktuell die Konto-Bewegung, die man auf seinem Konto drauf hat. Und man kann einstellen, dass er das dann alle Stunde aktualisiert. Für jemanden wie mich, der notorisch keinen Überblick über sein Konto hat...
Warum bin ich meine Konto-Zahl oben in meinem Display stehen? Ich glaub nicht.
Ich hab so das Bedürfnis, so langsam zum Gefühl dafür zu entwickeln, dass ein Konto peu à peu auch leer wird. Dass das nicht einfach irgendwann ist, dass man am EC-Automaten steht und es kommt kein Geld mehr raus, wie meine bisherige Erfahrung immer war. Und dass man dann einem einfällt, dass man schon seit ungefähr acht Monaten keine Rechnung mehr geschrieben hat und in aller schnelle Rechnung schreibt und dann bei den Kunden jammern geht, dass es auch möglichst schnell überweisen. Sondern dass so ein bisschen dieses Gefühl dafür entsteht, da kann man auch sich rechtzeitig drum kümmern. Das ist einfach mein Versuch, erwachsen zu werden. Mit Saldomat.
Das hat mich 15 Euro...
Erwachsen werden für 15 Euro.
Jetzt neu.
Das ist echt, finde ich, ein guter Preis.
Ich hab mir letztes Mal schon gesagt, ich warte noch ein bisschen ab, bis das iPhone-Application ein bisschen mehr up-to-date ist. Und dann könnte ich mir sowas auch nochmal angucken.
Es gibt bei dem iPhone-Programm... Wie habt ihr das... Das hab ich mir dann auch... Dann hab ich gedacht, jetzt will ich mal den iOutbank. Hattest du dann empfohlen, hab ich mir auch geholt. Kostet relativ viel. Und wie so 10 Euro. iOutbank.
Ach so, dieses iOutbank, ja. Darüber geredet letztes Mal.
Genau, und davon gibt's jetzt auch irgendwie eine Lite-Version für 80 Cent, mit der man nur ein Konto folgen kann.
Ich hab eh nur ein Konto.
Eben. Ich hätte auch mir die Lite-Version wahrscheinlich... Nee, ich hab mehr als ein Konto, aber ich will nur eins überwachen. Und ich hätte mir dann wahrscheinlich die Lite-Version gekauft. Aber so hab ich noch die teure Version.
Aber überweisen kann man damit immer noch nicht?
Überweisen mach ich ganz normal per Webinterface. Das geht bei der Postbank eigentlich ganz gut. Die haben echter Schick. Da braucht man auch keine... Da braucht man auch keine irgendwie diese Kurzpin. Und seine Bankkonto-Nummer muss man sagen. Da kann man sich richtig mit Usernamen melden. Das ist eigentlich ganz schick. Auf jeden Fall bin ich jetzt so kontostandstechnisch immer im Blick im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Das ist wirklich...
Wir werden gerade korrigiert. Also... Von Twitter, Josa, Frank Stohl. Dass HD nur auf Apple TV geht.
Geht nur, oder?
Genau. Und in den USA auch auf iTunes. Also das Programm kann es zwar, aber in Deutschland wird es noch nicht angeboten. Warum auch immer. Naja, kein Grund, Apple TV so teuer zu machen. Ja, naja, so ist das.
Aber Twitter!
Twitter!
Twitter! Ich hab ja letzt mal gesagt, dass ich mal so eine Liste an Twitter-Client zusammenstellen werde.
Die ist ziemlich lang geworden.
Die ist lang geworden?
Ich bin ja jetzt konvertiert.
Du bist ein Konvertierter. Von wo bist du denn konvertiert?
Na, ich hab wie alle eine Weile lang Twitterifik benutzt.
So ganz am Anfang. Genau, wie alle, wie ich das alle getan hab.
Genau, bin dann aber relativ lange dabei auch geblieben, weil ich immer festgestellt habe, als diese ganzen anderen, kamen diese, was kam denn da? Tweetdeck und so. Die haben ja alle dieses Feature gehabt, dass man sich den ganzen Bildschirm voll machen kann.
Also, Tweetdeck ist, da gibt es, ich hab mal so eine Liste zusammengestellt. Also Twitterifik natürlich.
Soll ich dir erstmal meine Timeline erzählen?
Na, okay, erst mal deine Timeline.
Naja, auf jeden Fall kamen diese ganzen kleinen Ziele immer den ganzen Bildschirm voll machen. Und ich hab festgestellt, das gefällt mir gar nicht. Also ich will gar nicht so einen Fullscreen, Twitter-Woll-Dingsbombs haben. Das war mir alles zu viel. Eventbox war mir auch zu viel. Das war mir alles irgendwie zu schwer und dann aber auch nicht wirklich praktisch genug. Ich glaub bei Eventbox hat sich allerdings auch, weil es sich irgendwie abgeschaltet hat, wegen Bezahl-Mich...
Eventbox hab ich sogar gekauft.
Hat's mir nicht genug Zeit gegeben, einfach ihm zu folgen. Deswegen hab ich's eingelassen. Und dann gab's noch irgendeinen anderen Issue. Ich weiß nicht mehr, auf jeden Fall war mir das alles zu viel. Dann hab ich zuletzt noch Nambu ausprobiert. Nambu war an sich ein ganz interessanter Ansatz, ist aber auch so ein Bildschirmvollmacher, wenn auch mit Mehrwert, dass man mehrere Timelines gleichzeitig verfolgen kann.
Das fand ich gar nicht so schlecht, aber mit mehr abgestürzt, die Blöde.
Genau, und dann wird er langsam mit vielen Tweets und so, und dann war er instabil und pipapo. Da kam zwar auch im laufenden Meter neue Versionen, aber in jeder stand drin irgendwie wieder ein Crashing-Buck, wieder ein Crashing-Buck, wieder ein Crashing-Buck. Dann auf das Account-Icon, dann marschiert das so smooth nach oben und so. Also gerade hier mit dem Mobile-Max-Account, den ich halt parallel noch bediene, ist das einfach cool. Also es ist sehr elegant gelöst, sehr unobstrusive und es nimmt sehr wenig Platz weg. Also ich hab einfach nur diese eine Timeline, auf die ich immer schaue. Und je nachdem, was ich dann halt links daneben in dieser dünnen Zeile noch anklicke, weiß ich halt, worauf ich dann verweise. Man kann ja wohl auch noch irgendwie Searches festmachen.
Na, Searches kann man leider nicht festmachen. Das ist so was, was ich ein bisschen vermisse. Also Searches kann man nur um ein Fenster aufmachen. Was ich ganz hübsch finde, wenn man doppelklick macht auf einen Tweet, der ein Reply auf irgendwas ist, dann sieht man die ganze Timeline dazu, wie es dazu gekommen ist. So hier zum Beispiel einen ganzen schönen Chat, wie ich ihn gerade jetzt hier habe.
Die Conversation.
Die Conversation. Man kann Tweetpicks direkt den Link anklicken. Es geht so ein hübsches Fenster auf, und man dann das Bild relativ groß sieht. Leider gibt es noch keine Möglichkeit, direkt auf die Seite von da aus drauf zu kommen. Man kann Bilder hochladen, indem man einfach die Datei nimmt und ins Fenster reinzieht, ins Nachrichtenfenster. Finde ich sehr schick. Also es sind echt... Ich dachte, ich würde bei Tweety eine ganze Menge vermissen. Ich vermisse auch ein bisschen was. Aber nicht genug, um nicht zu sagen, das ist doch der Client meiner Wahl.
Tweety.
Tweety. Ich kann jetzt mal so ein bisschen erzählen, was ich hier sage. Also Twitterrific natürlich, auf der langen Liste. Eventbox habe ich mir auch gekauft. Eventbox probiert ein bisschen zu viel, finde ich. Also da kann man den Google-Reader integrieren, was ich ganz furchtbar finde. Man kann seinen Facebook-Stream mit reinpacken, was ich so ganz okay finde, als Social-Alles-Dingsbums.
Weil Facebook ja dann auch wieder alles hintenrum sich auch nochmal wieder einverleitet.
Man sollte so ein Doppel draus nehmen. Auf Twitter follow ich jemanden, wenn mir das erst mal nicht mehr gefällt, dann follow ich den nicht mehr. Bei Facebook bin ich da mal vokabular ein bisschen gefangen. Will man jetzt jemanden gleich die Freundschaft kündigen, bloß weil man seine Nachrichten nicht mag? Also, ne, eigentlich nicht.
Waren dir jetzt nicht auch dieses Follower-Konzept ein bei Facebook?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich fand Eventbox, die Facebook-Integration, am Anfang ganz schick, hab's dann aber irgendwann nicht mehr genutzt. Aber was bei Eventbox ganz schön ist, man kann sich suchen, abspeichern. Und man kann bei Twitterern, die einem lieb und teuer sind, kann man zusätzlich nochmal sich deren Tweets nochmal separat anzeigen lassen, damit man von denen nichts verpasst. Was ich auch ganz praktisch finde. Also, wenn man so im allgemeinen Stream geht ja eine Menge unter, weil ich Follower 250 Leute.
Kann man eigentlich auch sagen, von dem User will ich immer nur die Neueste sehen, weil du bist ja zum Beispiel auch so ein Twitter-Spammer. Und dass ich sagen kann, von Max will ich immer nur eine sehen und den Rest nicht. Dass man erst irgendwie aufklappen muss oder sehen kann.
Max ist ein Twitter-Poet. Doch. Macht er.
Aber die Web 2.0-Witze, die Schmerzen bis heute.
Hat er gesagt, hat er eingesehen.
Nee, hab ich nicht eingesehen. Wir fangen einfach keine mehr an. Dann, was es noch ganz Hübsches gibt, ist Bluebird.
Also kann man das nur oder nicht, das Feature, dass man nur den letzten Tweet von einer Person sieht?
Nö.
Dann passt man ja auch mehr hin sozusagen.
Kenn ich nicht, nein. Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Kenn ich keinen, der das kann.
Also es wird der Programmierer als Feature hier. Request.
Macht mal. Bluebird finde ich ganz hübsch. Bluebird da vor allen Dingen. Sie ist so, kennt keine Sau, macht noch einen ziemlichen Betan-Eindruck. Hat aber eine sehr, sehr hübsche, sehr, sehr tolle Direct Message Darstellung. Also man sieht es.
Ist das der Kleine mit diesem absurden Video, was für ihn wirkt?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Gibt es auch dieses Video, wo sie alle irgendwie von ihrem Twitter... Ach nee, Entschuldigung, das war fürs iPhone. Ich vergesse. Aber es war auch noch was mit Bluebird.
Hier oben sieht man die einzelnen Leute, mit denen man als letztes so konvertiert, also mit denen, die ihr letztes Nachrichten geschickt habt.
Okay, den meinte ich nicht.
Sieht man so ein kleines Bläschen dran, wie viele neue Nachrichten von den Personen da sind, dann klickt man drauf und dann sieht man das quasi als Chat und kann auch direkt wieder unten antworten, indem man das unten in das Fenster reinpackt. Finde ich so ganz niedlich. Nambu hatten wir schon, Lounge gibt es da noch. Hinterlässt bei mir so ein bisschen gemischte Gefühle.
Lounge.
Also hatten ein paar sehr schicke Features. Also auch so dieses mittlerweile ja recht übliche. Also früher haben die Twitter-Klans ja so eher ausgesehen. So Twitterrific, eine Liste, so nur eine Zeitachse. Und mittlerweile sehen die ja doch mehr aus wie Mail-Programme, wo man links dann so quasi seine Ordner hat oder beziehungsweise die einzelnen verschiedenen Seiten. Und rechts dann die eigentlichen Nachrichten. Und Launch macht so auf den ersten Blick einen relativ soliden Eindruck. War bei mir allerdings auch ein bisschen hakelig. Und ich finde die eigens hässlich. Ich weiß, das klingt vielleicht total doof und überhaupt nicht richtig.
Ich hab mein Telefon nicht ausgeschaltet.
Menschenskinder.
Und das mir mit einer Podcast geohnt.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch Leute, die auf Twirl total stehen. Twirl ist ein Air-Up. Ich erzähle jetzt einfach mal weiter. Und Twirl ist nämlich so ein Air geschrieben, kann alles, kann suchen, abspeichern, kann identiker, kann beliebig viele Twitter-Accounts, kann halbtransparent, kann weißer Teufel was. Ist aber sagenhaft hässlich, weil in Air geschrieben. Ich mag es irgendwie nicht. Nee, Destroy Twitter ist auch ein Air, aber schön. Aber ganz kann quasi nichts. Also hat nur so ein absolutes... Destroy Twitter. Ja, ist halt so Designer-Twitter-Programm, würde ich mal sagen. Es gibt eine neue Version. Sieht halt so extrem reduziert aus, hat was echt Schickes. Sehr smoothe Animationen und sowas. Aber ich finde es schon irgendwie doof, wenn dann zum Beispiel die Favoriten nicht Favoriten heißen, sondern Saved. Weißte toll, warum. Ich will meine Sternchen haben. Achso, das finde ich bei Tweety auch einen schönen Bug, dass mein Favoriten wäre noch gar nicht so richtig ernst genommen, leider.
Und dein Favorit ist jetzt Tweety?
Mein Favorit ist Tweety.
Und deiner auch?
Meiner? Es ist der, den ich gerade benutze. Ich sag's mal so, das ist alles Work in Progress, aber es saugt deutlich weniger als Twitterific, weil bei Twitterific fehlt mir einfach die Möglichkeit, explizit auf meine Mentions, wie das jetzt so schön heißt, einzugehen. Also das, wo ich explizit gekrotet werde, auch von Leuten, denen ich unter Umständen nicht folge. Das ist für mich auch die wichtigste Quelle bei Twitter. Also einfach zu sehen, wer in irgendeiner Form sich auf mich bezieht bzw. versucht, wenn ihr Kontakt... Ja gut, das fällt dabei auch ab. Das finde ich aber eher, ehrlich gesagt, eher stört. Das hätte ich ganz gerne noch separat. Also so Retweets. Also finde ich zwar interessant, aber da steckt natürlich nicht viel Information für mich drin. Interessanter finde ich halt, wenn Leute mich was fragen oder, keine Ahnung, mich in irgendeinem anderen Kontext erwähnen halt.
Aber bei Twitterrific gehen Sachen gerne mal unter. Auch Direktnachrichten sind dann irgendwo ganz unten vergraben und man hat keine Chance, die wiederzufinden. Das finde ich auch immer doof.
Ja, also Twitterrific ist auch alt. Also das hat ja nun wirklich keinerlei Pflege mehr.
Aber soll doch demnächst der 2.0 kommen, oder?
Ja, soll demnächst kommen. Was soll denn hier alles demnächst kommen? Weil TextMate soll ja auch demnächst mal eine 2.0 kommen. Das hör ich jetzt auch schon seit zwei Jahren.
TextMate ist so ein bisschen das neue Duke Nukem Forever, oder?
Jaja, immer diese großen ambitionierten Releases. Das wird immer nix.
Wer hat da irgendwann mal gesagt, schön, die haben mit TextMate 1.0 so viel verdient, die liegen auf irgendeiner Insel rum, die sie sich vorher gekauft haben. Ist definitiv okay.
Das kann gut sein. Wobei irgendwie iPhone kill the Macintosh-Application, muss ich sagen. Es gibt ja jetzt so einen zunehmenden Maße Programme, die jetzt einfach brach liegen auf dem Mac, weil sie nicht mehr weiterentwickelt werden, weil die Developer aufs iPhone umgestiegen sind und da jetzt irgendwie sich mit einer kleinen Fubar ab eine goldene Nase verdienen und einfach den Rest liegen lassen, weil sie es gesehen haben.
Ja, die kommen alle wieder.
Also bei den Twitter-Klien, man sieht schon, dass die auch wiederkommen, weil es gibt jetzt so viele Twitter-Klien fürs iPhone, gute vor allen Dingen.
Ja, Twitter ist noch mal ein ganz anderes Ding, aber ich rede jetzt so von richtigen Ups, also bevor die Leute sich da irgendwie einabkämpfen. Also im Verhältnis zum Aufwand kann man einfach beim iPhone mehr Geld verdienen derzeit und das spricht sich rum.
Zumindest probieren sie erst mal alle.
Zumindest probieren sie es mal. Alle und viele haben auch schon diese Erfolge gehabt. Ja, und ich muss sagen, Macintosh mag es. Naja, also es ist ja nicht so, dass keine neuen Ups rauskommen würden, aber so richtig, so richtig, so richtig, also mir fehlt da was. Also es war schon mal mehr Drei irgendwie drin. Aber vielleicht ist man auch nur so ein bisschen verwöhnt von diesem ganzen Wahnsinn, der dem iPhone entgegenkommt. Bird House heißt übrigens dieser Client auf dem iPhone, wo sie wirklich ein großartig verpeiltes Video zugemacht haben. Das ist so ein Zusammenschnitt, glaube ich, 4-5 Minuten lang, wo dann irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Leute im Webcam-Style irgendwie mit schlechten Ton davon berichten, wie Bird House ihr Leben verändert hat. Und das ist so großartig überzogen und bekloppt. Schon wieder cool überzogen. Man merkt einfach, dass sie wirklich alle vollkommen übertreiben und dass es nicht so gedacht ist, dass man jetzt wirklich diese Cred Star als solche nehmen soll. Und das ist irgendwie geil.
Das ist gar nicht dieser Twitter Client.
Genau, das muss ich dazu sagen. Da gibt es jetzt schon zwei oder drei Tools, die das machen, die sozusagen nur dafür da sind, Drafts zu schreiben. Also du postest damit auch, aber du machst auch nicht sehr viel mehr und die kümmern sich sozusagen mehr ums Draft.
Also es geht nicht um den Konsum von Twitter-Nachrichten, sondern es geht um die Produktion. Um sozusagen das Vögel in die Produktion.
Ja, ich weiß, ich fühle mich nur gerade so ein. Aber du weißt, was ich meine. Aber ich denke, dass die normalen Twitter-Kleins, ich hoffe ja, dass Twitter von irgendwann nochmal verbessert wird. Mir fehlen da zwei, drei Sachen.
Mir fehlen vor allen Dingen jetzt bei Tweety Offen iPhone ein paar Sachen. Also Tweety Offen iPhone gibt es ja schon ein bisschen länger. Und Tweety Offen Mac hat ein paar Features, die Tweety Offen iPhone nicht hat. Zum Beispiel schicke DM-Darstellung. Schicke DM-Darstellung? Also die ist auf dem Mac, ist die auch so, dass man die nach Personen gruppiert sieht und dann so auch so eine Chat-Darstellung hat, quasi wie Twitter-Phone auf dem iPhone auch. Und die iPhone-Version hat das leider nicht. Ganz, ganz furchtbar. Und ich will natürlich irgendwann, irgendwann sollen die mal eine Sync-Funktion kriegen, also dass ich auf dem iPhone immer an der Stelle bin. Das finde ich ja übrigens bei Tweety ganz witzig.
Kann Twitter noch nicht? Was sieht das API nicht vor?
Die API sieht das nicht vor, aber ich meine so als Tweety, die könnten das in dem Programm, könnten die noch irgendwo sich in den Server hinstellen und könnten da die aktuelle Scroll-Position sich merken.
Also, das könnte man machen, aber ich glaube, das werden wir über kurz oder lang bei Twitter auch sehen.
Das finde ich übrigens eines der schönsten Features an Tweety, von dem ich es gar nicht gedacht hätte. Und zwar die haben ja, so andere Twitter-Clients haben ja eigentlich immer diesen gelesen-ungelesenen Status bei irgendwelchen Nachrichten. Und Tweety merkt sich ja einfach nur die Scroll-Position, an dem man als letztes war.
Gibt's bei Nambu auch das Feature?
Ja, bei Nambus funktioniert es aber nicht.
Das stimmt.
Bei Tweety ist es, du machst den kleinen zu, du machst ihn wieder auf und es ist genau an der gleichen Stelle, an der es vorher war und du hast einfach nach oben hin noch ein paar neue Nachrichten, die du noch nicht gelesen hast.
Das benutze ich mittlerweile auch. Da muss man nicht alle irgendwie als gelesen markieren.
Man muss ja nicht mit der Leertaste durchgehen.
Man scrollt einfach aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Das ist total geil. Das ist wirklich eines der besten Features in dem Programm.
Was mir fehlt bei iPhone und bei Mac für Twitter-Klient ist, Tags vorzudefinieren, die ich schnell einführen kann.
Das stimmt.
Gerade auf dem iPhone, wenn man auf so einer Konferenz rumgammelt und fast sowieso jeden Tweet damit machen will, ich das einfach als Default vorgebe. Jeder Tweet mit diesem Ding oder zumindest irgendwie ein einfaches Keypad, was man so reinfährt oder sonst irgendwas, um das schnell einzugeben.
Ich hab da so ein paar Features, die ich... Also Edwin ist ja noch nicht ganz tot, auch wenn es vielleicht den Eindruck macht im Augenblick. Und ich hab da so eine Feature-Liste, was für Edwin 2.0 kommen soll und... oder sitzt da auch hin und wieder schon mal dran. Und da gehört das definitiv zu, so einer Hashtag Completion. Dass man so ein paar Hashtags, die man in letzter Zeit verwendet hat, entweder oder die gerade top aktuell sind, dass man die einfach in so einer Liste drin hat und da raus wählen kann. Das fehlt auf jeden Fall.
Ich werd hier gerade im Chat angesprochen, aber ich kann gerade nicht mitlesen. Was wollte ich sagen? Ich wollte das Thema wechseln.
Du wolltest das Thema wechseln.
Genau, aber wir sind gerade bei praktischen Macintosh-Applikationen, wo ja sonst uns immer so viel vorgeworfen wird, dass wir nicht so viel über Macintosh-Applikationen reden, sondern immer über das iPhone. Zurecht übrigens. Schon mal gehört?
Damit kannst du auf die Bibliothek zugreifen, wie auf ein Dateisystem, oder?
Genau, und zwar unter Zuhilfenahme von MacFuse, diesem User-Level-Filesystem, kannst du sozusagen deine iTunes-Bibliothek und auch die von deinem iPod, wenn er angeschlossen ist, sozusagen als Filesystem einblenden. Das hat dann sozusagen ein definiertes Verhalten.
Auch die vom iPhone?
Also ich hab's noch nie ausprobiert, muss ich sagen. Aber könnte ich eigentlich mal ausprobieren.
Vom iPhone wahrscheinlich nicht, weil da kommen sie ja nicht dran. Bei der iPod, der mountet sich ja. Und da ist sie in einem Ordner versteckt, bei dem iPhone ist das ja nicht so. Deswegen nehm ich mal an, da erst mal nicht.
Kann sein, weiß ich nicht. Hab ich nicht ausprobiert, ich hab's auch mit dem iPod nicht ausprobiert. Mangelst eines iPods. Die sind mir alle verlustig gegangen, die ich hatte.
Und wofür nutzt du das? Also was mir jetzt als erstes einfallen würde, um mit R-Synch ein vernünftiges Backup machen zu können.
Wenn man von anderen Leuten mal, da kommt jemand ins iPod und führt den Song vor und du willst den haben und dann geht's mal wieder nicht. Und dann macht man es halt mit diesem iTunes FS. Weil das war schon mal so ein Problem von anderen Leuten, um das vom iPod runterzuholen.
Das stimmt, aber dafür hab ich...
Also es gibt tausende Tools hier anzwischen, aber die sind ja alle irgendwie, entweder die kosten halt richtig Geld und kannst du nicht ausprobieren, ob sie wirklich cool sind. Und die, die kein Geld kosten, die sind dann irgendwie nicht cool oder du kennst sie nicht und das ist immer irgendwie so ein Problem. Okay, iTunes FS kannten wir bis eben ja auch nicht. Aber das ist zumindest auch so eine Lösung, da ist kein Programm drum, sondern du benutzt es halt direkt und ich brauch da auch kein Programm drum rum. Ich will das eigentlich so manuell brausen.
Ja, damit lässt sich auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge sehr interessant abstrahieren.
Über MacFuse haben wir schon mal... da gibt es auch Fusion gibt es ja auch. MacFusion heißt das glaube ich dann. Das ist so ein User-Interface für den SSH und SFTP und FDP-Client, der in MacFuse drin ist.
Ja.
Auch ein sehr praktisches Werkzeug.
Wobei ich da mittlerweile dieses Expand-Reif ja noch...
Ja, was kann das, was MacFusion nicht kann?
Das kann ich dir jetzt im Einzelnen nicht so runterbeten, aber ich finde, das ist einfach so dieses Ich-will-auf-SSH-Zugreifen konsequent einfach macht.
Also die 30 Dollar haben mich da ein bisschen abgeschreckt, weil...
Ja, mit dem Geld ist das immer so eine Sache. Ich benutze das hier auch nur so testweise, weil ich eigentlich nur sehr kurze Zugriffe Zeit habe und das nicht die ganze Zeit benutze. Ich kann auch noch mit ohne diese ganzen Tools arbeiten. Außerdem habe ich mir mal Transmit gekauft, was das ja auch alles supportet. Die funktionieren auch schön so mit SSH-Keys. Das ist schon ganz prima. Ja, erinnert ihr euch noch, wir haben ja letztes Mal, danach habe ich ja auch die Sendung benannt.
Wer kauft wen?
Wer kauft wen? Und wer hat wen gekauft?
Sun hat Oracle übernommen.
Fast, denkst du? Oracle ist ja so ein Phantom. Ich meine, Sie sind jetzt offiziell zweitgrößter Software-Anbieter der Welt, sagen Sie?
Ist der Kauf dann schon durch?
Sagt man.
Oder wären Sie es auch ohne?
Wer war denn vorher größer? Wer war denn vorher zweitgrößter?
Bevorher, bevor Sie es waren? Das weiß ich nicht.
Also Oracle ist schon verdammt fett.
Das geht halt so nach Umsatz und so. Die machen halt Big Business und so.
Ich glaube SAP war früher mal...
Mit SAP boxen die sich auf jeden Fall.
Dritter und vielleicht waren die ja zwischendurch mal zweiter.
Aber das kann gut sein. Gibt es bestimmt irgendwann in der Wikipedia eine Liste von Software-Companies, aber ich finde auch diese Zahlen irgendwie auch verwirrend, weil das lässt sich auch alles so nicht so direkt miteinander vergleichen, weil der Einfluss, der jetzt ja eigentlich viel wichtiger ist, der lässt sich dauerhaft eigentlich nur begrenzt ablesen, weil das Oracle unser Leben beeinflusst, glaube ich. Das können wir alle nur im Kopf schütteln, oder?
Sagen wir mal so, wenn Oracle...
Hast du das letzte Mal was mit Oracle zu tun gehabt?
Vorhin.
Dann sagen wir es... Ich meine, was meinst du? Womit machst du deine Mails? Wenn alle Oracle-Datenbanken dieser Welt mit einmal aufhören würden, zu funktionieren, hätten wir einen Haufen Rechnungen weniger wahrscheinlich in unserer Inbox.
Ich glaube, die meisten Oracle-Datenbanken hören sowieso am laufenden Meter auf, zu funktionieren.
Meinst du?
Ja, das taugt auch alles überhaupt nichts, das Zeug. Oracle-Datenbanken, also wann auch immer ich mal in meinem Leben an Oracle-Datenbanken gerannt werde, habe ich nur Leute gesehen, die schwitzen und irgendwie schimpfen.
Na, das ist noch richtig, das ist noch richtig. Arbeit halt. Ich hab heute mal wieder mit Windows 7 da gesessen, da möchtest du dich auch am liebsten aufhängen.
Ich weiß nicht, also vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach ignorant. Na, da bin ich ignorant. Ich bin da ignorant.
Das sind ja die Leute, die von dem Oracle sitzen.
Die kenne ich einfach nur als teuer und scheiße. Ich hab so oft so Szenarien mitbekommen und ich rede jetzt eigentlich wirklich von Zeiträumen, die länger als zehn Jahre her sind.
Damals.
Ja, na gut, aber das sah ja auch schon eine Menge aus. Wo dann so Oracle-Installationen nicht liefen und so Support-Verträge aktiviert wurden und dann kamen so Oracle-Mitarbeiter, die zwei Tage lang irgendwie an diesem System rumgezuppelt haben. Danach lief es halt immer noch nicht. Das sind so für mich bleibende Erinnerungen.
Aber mit Oracle kann man schon, ich weiß nicht, gibt es irgendjemanden, mit dem man in der Größenordnung Datenbankungen hochziehen kann, wie diese doch?
Postgres.
Geht das mit denen? Ich weiß nicht, die sind doch nicht sonderlich schnell, oder? Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Postgres ist schnell und Postgres ist stabil. Und Postgres...
Ist voll toll.
Du bist totaler Postgres-Fan.
ja, also... Frag mal. Also, ich kenne keine Leute, die schlechte Erfahrungen mit Postgres gemacht haben.
Ich bin nicht dazu gekommen, weil das einzige Projekt...
Im Gegensatz zu Leuten, die MySQL begegnet sind, in ihrem Leben. Also, nach MySQL-Flüche habe ich gerade vorhin noch auf Twitter an mir vorbeirieseln sehen. So was nehme ich bei PostgreSQL nicht wahr. Also, PostgreSQL ist auf jeden Fall Datenbank-Software für Erwachsene. MySQL nicht.
Was gibt's denn an MySQL auszusetzen?
Na, eine Menge.
Was kann MySQL nicht, was PostgreSQL kann?
Na ja, dem SQL-Standards zum Beispiel zu entsprechen.
Oracle deswegen.
Na ja, das ist jetzt der Spin, den ich noch ziehen wollte. Aber MySQL ist seine eigene Welt. MySQL ist MySQL und kommt halt so langsam über die Jahre dann auch mal so auf das Feature-Set, was PostgreSQL hat.
Ja, ich glaube, das haben sie schon lange nicht.
Sowas wie ein Backup. Nein. Also mit dem Feature-Set von PostgreSQL kann MySQL das noch lange nicht aufnehmen.
Sicher?
Ja.
Ich hab mich lange nicht mal mit PostgreSQL beschäftigt.
So ist das aber. Und auf jeden Fall, mein MySQL, ich kann erst vor ein paar Jahren dann auch mal so ein Backup im laufenden Betrieb machen. Ist ja nicht so, dass es eine Datenbank ist. Klar, Datenpunkt fährt man ja um 17 Uhr abends runter und morgens um 9, wenn die Mitarbeiter kommen, dann wird die wieder hochgefahren.
Stimmt's?
Also ich hab, um ehrlich zu sein, ich hab noch nie schlechte Erfahrungen damit gemacht, einen MySQL-Datenbank im laufenden Betrieb wegzubekappen.
PostgreSQL entspricht auf jeden Fall, hat immer die ganzen aktuellen SQL-Standards implementiert. Die können einfach alle Features, die haben halt auch irgendwie mal so ein...
Ja, aber SQL ist doch sowieso für ein Arsch.
PostgreSQL ist so wie die Luxus-PBSD.
Ich meine, bei MySQL ist das schon sogar die Userverwaltung in Tabellen und so ein Kack.
Das find ich ehrlich gesagt ganz gut.
Aber wie man SQL-Standard wieder zu funktionieren hat, da gibt's halt so richtig Commands dafür, die das machen.
Nee, die gibt's bei MySQL auch.
Mit Permissions, wo du da nicht so eine Batterie von irgendwelchen Feldern in irgendwelchen Tabellen mit Y und N füllen musst und so ein Kack.
Nee, die gibt's übrigens bei MySQL schon ewig. Die entsprechenden Befehler, die werden bloß nur intern in einer Tabelle verwaltet und du kannst sie halt einsehen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall immer anders bei MySQL. MySQL hat auf jeden Fall immer seinen eigenen Weg gegangen und das geht auch schöner. Wie auch immer. Ich werde nicht so viel darüber reden. Ich bin auch kein Datenbank-Experte. Ich hab nur so meine Erfahrungen und ich weiß, warum ich mal SQL meide.
Also ich hab am Wochenende einen Artikel über SQL generell gelesen. Die meinten, SQL ist fällig, wo ich auch zustimme, weil für moderne Web-Applikationen ist SQL einfach total dämlich.
Ganz andere Gesprächsthemenkarten. Was da schon CRE drüber? Eine sehr valide? Also ich meine darauf, dass SQL abgelöst wird, da warten wir alle schon lange drauf. Aber das wird glaube ich so schnell nicht stattfinden, leider.
Fürchte ich auch.
Ich hab zumindest schon mal CRE gehabt, wo Alternativen vorgestellt wurden, auch wenn die sich noch nicht besonders erfolgreich gebärten.
Ich kenne jetzt einen Hörer, der jetzt im Zweifelsfall so hüppend vorm Radio sitzt und wenn ich das nicht sage, dann bringt er mich um. CouchDB ist ja ein ganz knuffiger Ansatz. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den kennt.
Wir waren aber noch bei Oracle.
Machen wir erstmal Oracle, dann erzähle ich mal ein bisschen.
Genau, finde ich auch interessant. Oracle kauft Zahn anstatt IBM. Wir haben ja viel darüber geredet, warum es bei IBM gut passen würde, weil das ist ja auch ihr Business.
Ich habe ja gesagt, IBM will nur den Preis hochtreiben, damit sich ein anderes nicht zu billig holt. Und die haben ja auch überboten, die sind ja auf 7,4 Milliarden gegangen oder so was.
Ja, 400 Millionen Dollar.
Aber hätte IBM nicht mitgespielt, hätten sie es vielleicht für 6 gekriegt.
Das ist doch alles Pipifax-Preise, ich meine, Millionen Dollar, das kratzt sie doch am Arsch.
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist doch nichts.
Wie groß ist denn Ruckel? Ich habe keine Ahnung. IBM ist ja noch nicht mehr so groß.
Ja, da holen die sich Kredite und so. Okay, jetzt hat sich ein Kredit zu holen, das ist vielleicht jetzt auch nicht so einfach, wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, dass sie sich in diesen Laden jetzt einverleiben wollen und sie kriegen damit eine ganze Menge Assets, mit denen sie eigentlich nichts anfangen können. Und vor allem Oracle ist eine Bude, die macht irgendwie Linux, hat sein eigenes Datenbanksystem. Das Einzige, wo sie wirklich was verwenden, was bei Sun wirklich sozusagen eine große Rolle spielt, ist Java. Also Java ist für Oracle wichtig, sie haben sehr viel in Java geschriebene Software. Bloß, naja, das könnten sie halt auch machen, ohne die zu kaufen. Und auf jeden Fall ist Oracle keine Hardware-Bude. Ich hab so ein Statement gelesen von irgendeinem Oracle-Heini, weiß jetzt nicht genau, welcher das war, ob das der Chef war oder nicht. Auf jeden Fall meinte er, naja, jetzt wären wir ja der Einzige, oder auf jeden Fall wären wir ja jetzt ein Systemanbieter.
Oracle ist kleiner als Apple.
Ich glaube, da sind sie gerade alle ein bisschen kleiner als Apple, oder? Ja, das schwenkt doch nicht immer ab. Ich versuche hier gerade einen Gedanken zu fassen.
Die Zahlen, oh Gott, die stürzen gerade ab.
Hallo, fällt euch was auf? Sie sagen, Sie wären jetzt ein Systemanbieter. Also Sie können jetzt Software und Hardware in einem anbieten.
Dann kommt nicht nur der Software-Typ, der schwitzt und an der Software sitzt. Dann schicken Sie gleich noch einen schwitzenden Hardware-Typen mit.
Das glaube ich auch.
Der hat dann mal Grund zu schwitzen.
Ja, aber ich finde es interessant, dass das in dem Business wirklich eine Rolle spielen soll. Ich meine, klar, warum nicht? Ich meine, Computer wissen wir jetzt alles sehr komplex und irgendwie so eine Systemintegration zu machen, das ist irgendwie nicht einfach. Und Oracle schippt Software, wo sie wirklich so eine komplette Großfirma von oben bis unten organisieren. Und jetzt liefern sie quasi die Hardware noch mit dazu.
Also für einen Kunden könnte das ganz spannend sein, wenn vorher Datenbankhersteller und Hardwarehersteller die Schuld aufeinander gegenseitig schön zugeschoben hat, wird das jetzt in einzelnen Abteilungen ablaufen, innerhalb der selben Firma.
Und die werden nicht so schnell in Abteilungen die Schuld hin und her schieben.
Auf jeden Fall wird es irgendwelche Implikationen haben.
Gott, wir können jetzt zugucken, wie Oracle hier abstürzt. Und gerade war es noch bei 1976, jetzt bei 1973.
Ich mach das mal aus, Max ist abgelenkt. Ja, aber es ist doch ein guter Move eigentlich, dass die so ein komplettes System anbieten wollen.
Gut, vielleicht magst du dich das für ihr bisschen aussehen. Aber was bleibt von Sun übrig? Ich meine, derzeit bieten sie Linux an. Sie machen Linux-Support.
Das merkt man doch die Eiern halt gerade rum. Linux-Support, was ist denn das?
Nein, nicht Sun. Oracle ist ein Linux-Support. Sun macht Solaris. Und Sun macht vor allem Open Solaris und versucht halt da richtig Community drum zu machen. Sie haben sich ja sogar den Projekt-Gründer, Leiter von Debian gekauft, um dieses Open Solaris nach vorne zu treiben. Ich weiß nicht, wieviel Erfolg sie da schon haben, auf jeden Fall probieren sie das halt. Um sozusagen auch wirklich da eine Alternative zu bieten zu Solaris. Und sie sind ja immer noch auch lizenzmäßig eher im anderen Lager. Jetzt kommt irgendwie Oracle und kriegt MySQL vor die Füße geschmissen, was sie wahrscheinlich nicht mögen, weil sie ja lieber ihren Oracle-Kram verkaufen. Also sie haben jetzt sozusagen die beiden Database-Sachen. Oracle hatte vorher schon InnoDB gekauft.
Und Sun hat MySQL erst gekauft für 1,4 Milliarden?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie dafür bezahlt haben.
1,3 oder was?
Jüngst erst einverleibt worden. Also mir ist unklar, was dabei rauskommt. Und vor allem sollte dem Kunden sehr unklar sein, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich glaube, Sun wird jetzt erst mal ein bisschen zergestückelt.
Ja, die Frage ist, was davon übrig dann bleibt. Also ob das Sun so, ob Sun dann noch Sun bleibt. Also wird es Sun überhaupt als Marke noch weiterhin geben? Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sie die Marke beibehalten.
Ich würde mal behaupten, dass die Marke wesentlich bekannter ist als Oracle. Also Sun hat ja doch immer noch irgendwie so ein relativ positives Image. Die probieren immerhin wenigstens hin, was wollen gegen Oracle, das sind einfach nur die Leute in den grauen Anzügen, die Datenbanken verkaufen und das seit 30 Jahren tun.
Dann könnte es natürlich auch eine Auswirkung auf ZFS haben. Weil es durchaus sein kann, dass Oracle dann eben auch sagt, ok, jetzt machen wir ZFS auch mal Dual License auch noch als GPL.
Oracle ist ja die Firma, die auch dieses Butter- oder Better FS auf Linux irgendwie losgetreten haben.
Na ja, aber ich meine...
Sind dann aber wohl ausgestiegen.
Guck mal, so schlecht passt das doch alles gar nicht zusammen. Ich meine, auf der einen Seite haben sie bisher eine Datenbank gehabt und wahrscheinlich noch so irgendwelche, so dieses ganze Human Resources Zeug und weißt ja toll was, so dieser Anwendungsbereich war in Oracle ja noch relativ groß. Jetzt haben sie sich noch das Betriebssystem und die Hardware dazu gekauft, auf der ihre Datenbank in der Mehrzahl der Fälle wahrscheinlich sowieso läuft. Dann haben wir ja diesen ZFS Vortrag damals bei diesem ZFS Treffen, auf dem wir waren, im New Thinking Store. Haben die ja auch ganz toll davon, oder habe ich auf jeden Fall gehört, dass MySQL, dass man das direkt auf ZFS laufen lassen kann und dass das so ein toller Anwendungsfall wäre. Das haben sie sich mit ihren Oracle Datenbanken bestimmt auch mal angeguckt. Und es gibt ja sowieso, gibt es nicht sogar ein Oracle Betriebssystem quasi, was da nichts anderes macht, auf bare metal als die Datenbank zur Verfügung zu stellen. So quasi so ein Minimalbetriebssystem, was nur die Datenbank laufen lässt.
Was soll das bringen?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich glaube, was du meinst, ist, dass das...
Also auf jeden Fall, als Dateisystem gibt es ja Oracle quasi. Oder nicht als Dateisystem, sondern dass du eben eine Platte formatierst, die nur als Oracle Datenbank zu benutzen ist.
Na man kann halt eine Platte als Block Device direkt dem Oracle geben. Die machen dann nicht das Native File System, sondern die benutzt die Platte direkt.
Danke für die wesentlich bessere Formulierung. Und wäre das nicht sinnvoll, das auch...
Oder das Betriebssystem auch gleich Native zu formatieren, nur für die Datenbank zu benutzen. Ja, also ein Betriebssystem hochzuziehen, was performt und gut funktioniert und sich administrieren lässt, das macht man mal nicht mal so eben. Also du meinst, sie wollen jetzt Open Solaris dafür nehmen?
Zum Beispiel. Ein abgespecktes.
Ja, das heißt dann demnächst nicht mehr Open Solaris, sondern Oracle Solaris.
Mir ist das unklar. Auf jeden Fall Oracle hat da ein sehr, ein Oracle Blick drauf. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das der Firmenkultur von Sun so zugutekommt. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da die Axt irgendwo angesetzt wird, um das für sie auch funktionieren zu lassen und keine Ahnung. Also ich bin nicht beeindruckt von dem Kauf. Ich glaube, dass das eher fail.
Also ob das wirklich wahnsinnig viel bringt, macht keiner.
Bin ich Oracle, bin ich Sun? Also in meinen Augen ist Sun geschwächt. Das ist klar. Also Oracle ist eine Firma mit einem unklaren Eigeninteresse und wo überhaupt nicht klar ist, was Sache ist. Und das wird diesen laden. Also ich denke, dass die Sun-Mitarbeiter auf jeden Fall alle verunsichert sind. So tiefst.
Na, obwohl das ist wahrscheinlich schon zu lange her. Der Maya-Chefentwickler ist doch irgendwann mal hin gegangen. Relativ plötzlich bei Sun.
Ja, da ist die ganze Truppe da irgendwie abhandengekommen, glaube ich.
Na, das sind wahrscheinlich schon zwei Firmenkulturen, die ja irgendwann aufeinander knallen werden. Ich gebe euch recht, es klingt nicht unplausibel, dass dabei von Sun nicht allzu viel übrig bleibt.
Tja, na hoffen wir mal, dass das ZFS überlebt, weil das ist das Einzige, woran ich wirklich interessiert bin. Und D-Trace. Überhaupt, Betriebssystementwicklung, das können die. Die machen schon ordentlich.
Um das D-Trace mache ich mir gar nicht so Sorgen, weil ich glaube, das ist noch nicht ganz so komplex, dass man es auch noch irgendwie außer Hause weiterentwickeln könnte. Aber bei dem ZFS, da sehe ich nicht so richtig, dass da von extern irgendwie auch schon Sachen so richtig eingeflossen sind, außer so kleine Bugfixes oder so, aber so größere Geschichten sind da noch nicht gekommen, was wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach ist bei so einem komplexen System wie ZFS.
Ich erzähl jetzt mal dreieinhalb Sätze zu CouchDB, oder? Ja, wir sagen mal. Das hab ich irgendwann mal auf dem Barkend gesehen. Sag ich seinen Namen vergessen, wie hieß der, der das vorher geführt hat? Und zwar ist das ein Spin-Off von irgendeinem ehemaligen IBM-Mitarbeiter. Super, weiter so installieren. Ich mach jetzt mal. Tut einfach so, als ob das alles mit einem Fragezeichen zu versehen ist, was ich jetzt gerade erzähle. Und das ist eine Datenbank, die überhaupt nicht im klassischen SQL-Sinne arbeitet, weil man sowas heutzutage ja eigentlich auch nicht wirklich braucht. Also eine SQL-Datenbank ist ja, man legt verschiedene Felder an, Datenbankfelder, hat man da ein ID-Feld, dann hat man Vornamenfeld, Nachnamenfeld und so im heutigen Entwicklungsprozess ändert sich ja so oft was. Man muss so oft an die scheiß Datenbankstruktur ran, dass das nervt. Das sind wirklich zwei Welten, die nicht so richtig zusammenpassen. Und bei CouchDB, die haben jetzt, da braucht man nicht irgendwelche Treiber oder sowas, wie bei bisherigen Sprachen. Also für jede Programmiersprache braucht man mehr SQL-Treiber, damit er überhaupt kommunizieren kann. Das läuft in Zukunft alles per HTTP, so wie wir es kennen. Also CouchDB hat quasi einen kleinen Web-Server eingebaut. Und mit dem kommuniziere ich per REST. Also ich schicke da ein GET-Request hin, wenn ich was aus der Datenmark rausholen will. Oder ich schicke ein POST-Request hin, wenn ich Daten drin speichern will. Und ich bekomme dann JSON-Daten zurück. Also Daten, die ich zum Beispiel in JavaScript direkt abspeichern kann, direkt weiterverarbeiten kann, aber die ich auch in jeder anderen Sprache, weil einen JSON-Parser gibt es nun wirklich für jede Scheißsprache. Also das ist mittlerweile und zur Not schreibt man sich relativ schnell selber ein. Das heißt, man kann eigentlich in quasi jeder Programmiersprache so aus dem Stand so eine Couch-DB nutzen. Man braucht keine Tabellen einzulegen, weil man schmeißt einfach Daten drauf und die werden dann abgespeichert. Und wie sie abgespeichert werden, ist nicht dein Problem. Es gibt aber trotzdem die Möglichkeit, Daten abzufragen, ähnlich wie bei einer klassischen SQL-Datenbank. Bloß halt nicht über SQL-Befehle. Wo das Ganze noch ein bisschen hakt, wie ich finde, ist, es gibt keinerlei Userverwaltung und so weiter und so fort, wo ich dann irgendwann mal gefragt habe, wie stellt ihr euch das vor? Wo dann so relativ schnippische Antworten kamen, so ach komm, Userverwaltung, da setzt du einfach einen zweiten Client auf, machst einen Proxy davor und so was. Find ich aber schon, dass da irgendwie noch ein bisschen mehr fällig ist. Aber für so kleinere Projekte, wenn man einfach mal so eine Session storen will, oder eben wie oft hat man tatsächlich heutzutage noch, wenn man so Applikationsentwicklung macht, Web-Applikation, wie oft hat man da wirklich strukturierte Daten und nicht einfach nur Objekte, die man irgendwo reinschmeißen will?
Also CouchDB ist eine sogenannte Document-oriented Database. Das heißt, man hat so ein Dokument und es hat keine relationale Datenbank. Und dann kannst du das alles... Mach mal den Ton aus. Ja, mein Telefon ist... Nicht sonst komm ich immer automatisch gegen diesen Schalter, dass alles ruhig ist und heute nicht. Das heißt, es ähnelt sozusagen einem XML-Storage.
Genau.
Das ist an sich eine ganz tolle Idee. Weil dieser ganze relationale Kack, der nervt.
Ohne Ende.
Das ist wirklich richtig stumpf. Und man will das eigentlich nicht.
Also wie lange wir schon, ich schon dran gesessen habe, irgendwelche dämlichen End-zu-End-Relationen zu formulieren in irgendwelchen doofen Datenbanken, das nervt.
Mit ID's und Schnickes und Gebührs.
Dann braucht man eine Zwischentabelle und...
Genau, das ist wirklich anstrengend. Allerdings waren halt andere Sachen nicht unbedingt so performant. Und ich mach das ja auch ähnlich, ohne so eine Datenbank. Hier zum Beispiel Chaos Radio CC CDE, das ist ja alles XML sozusagen. Also der ganze Content, der da vorliegt, die Datenbank quasi, ist im Prinzip auch ein Dokument. Das ist so ein Storage mit irgendwie einem Top-Level-Element. Irgendwie hier ist alles und darunter ist dann irgendwie alles in einem XML-Dokument. Tatsächlich ist es aufgeteilt in verschiedene XML-Files.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ein großes Dokument, das klingt nicht so, als ob es beliebig skalieren würde.
Nö, es skaliert auch nicht beliebig, aber es ist halt einfach mal cool für die Ablage und das Design der Daten. Weil wenn ich irgendwo neue Informationen anlegen will, dann schreibe ich die halt einfach mit rein. Und ich muss nicht irgendein Schema anpassen und ich muss nicht irgendwelche Tabellendefinitionen neu machen und neue rebuilden und was nicht alles. Und Relationen gibt es sowieso nicht. Ich schreibe das halt rein und in Relation stelle ich das durch meinen Code. Aber halt irgendwelche IDs, was weiß ich, da ist halt die List auf Podcasts und dann hat jeder Podcast seine List auf Episodes. Die haben alle irgendwie eine ID und dann ist das halt einfach so ein TRI, der sich daraus ergibt, so ein Dokument-TRI eben, wie in jedem XML-File. Und wenn ich die halt in Relation setzen will, dann adressiere ich das halt in dem Fall halt mit XPath, mit dieser Pfadartigen Beschreibungssprache und kann mir dann eben diese Information aus diesem TRI zusammen glauben. Das ist dann zwar nicht schnell, aber es ist eben für mich sehr einfach, meine Daten dort abzulegen. Und ich vermute mal, CouchDB macht das ähnlich.
Genau. Also was mir jetzt noch einfällt bei CouchDB, was man ja gerade bei MySQL gerne hat, also wir kennen ja alle dieses schöne Twitter-Phänomen, das Twitter gerne mal ein bisschen lahmt und das liegt vermutlich nach wie vor daran, dass alles, was die speichern, ihre Datenbank, an einer einzigen gigantischen MySQL-Datenbank. Und jeder, der schon mal mit MySQL zu tun hat, so MySQL-Server auf zwei aufzuteilen, ist quasi ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Also braucht man wirklich sehr viel Fachwissen dafür, damit das überhaupt halbwegs läuft. Ich verfüge bei diesem Wissen nicht. Bei CouchDB ist das, du stellst einen zweiten Server daneben, schmeißt das rüber, die Synchronie können sich zum Beispiel regelmäßig mal synchronisieren. Du kannst die zwischendurch offline schalten. Also du machst eine Kopie einer CouchDB-Datenbank, die irgendwo online verfügbar ist, ziehst die lokal auf deinen Rechner runter und sobald die sich das nächste Mal sehen, synchronisieren die sich. Dinge, die man bei klassischen Datenbanken einfach komplett knicken kann.
Weißt du, in was das geschrieben ist?
Ich glaube auch Erlang ist damit dabei.
Ja, in Erlang. Bemerkenswert, ne?
Das sind echt lustige Sachen.
Die Telefonanlagensprache.
Ich weiß nicht, Erlang läuft mir in letzter Zeit sehr, sehr häufig über den Weg.
Naja, so E-Jabba-D, der performanteste Jabba-Server, ist auch in Erlang geschrieben. Ich hab das mal in ChaosRally Express zu Erlang gemacht. Verb, Verb. Erlang ist für Gleichzeitigkeit gebaut.
Sollten wir nicht mal eine Werbesendung drüber schreiben?
So einen speziellen Jingle irgendwie so. Das tue ich eh schon. Gleichzeitigkeit ist ja ein echtes Problem. Viele Sprachen, also die meisten Sprachen, haben keinerlei Abstraktion dafür. Und auch wenn hier und da mal so die Ford Libraries für Threading sind oder populäre Frameworks wie Twisted und Python, die halt die Gleichzeitigkeit von Dingen in irgendeiner Form einfacher machen, hast du nicht wirklich eine Orientierung der Sprache dafür. Erlang gehört halt zu den Sprachen, die das eben von Haus aus tun, die sozusagen von diesen ganzen Gleichzeitigkeiten der Dinge ausgehen und dafür optimiert sind und von daher eine ganz andere Skalierfähigkeit von Haus aus mitbringen. Und bei solchen Sachen wie Java, wo so ein Server wirklich mit unglaublich vielen Sachen zu tun hat, und ich habe auch irgendwie immer noch die Vermutung, dass Twitter, der Twitter-Rewrite, dass sie da am Ende des Tages auch irgendwas Erlangiges genommen haben, hätte mich nicht überrascht. Der Facebook-Chat ist auch in Erlang geschrieben.
Meinen Sie, Sie sind schon fertig mit Twitter-Rewrite? Ich glaube.
Keine Ahnung, ob sie schon fertig sind, aber ich meine, sie werden sich irgendwann mal für ihre Werkzeuge entschieden haben, bloß wie die Entscheidungen da gefallen sind, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt. Es ist nur so eine... Ich sage noch nicht mal, ich vermute, dass es Erlang ist. Ich sage nur, wenn ich feststellen würde, dass da Erlang zum Einsatz kommt, würde es mich nicht wundern. Ich habe gesehen davon, dass die Zahl der Erlang-Pur auf diesem Planeten noch sehr überschaubar zu sein scheint.
Also ich gehe ja mal davon aus, wenn die bei Twitter irgendwann mal einen kompletten Revive machen, dann werden wir plötzlich eine Feature-Explosion erleben, weil im Augenblick hat man ja immer das Gefühl, dass die nichts anfassen hat.
Ja, wir haben eine Feature-Explosion. Ich meine, das Ding skaliert jetzt mittlerweile seit einem Jahr weit gut. Es gab mal eine Phase, da war es jeden Tag zwei Stunden da oder länger.
Das Problem ist mittlerweile im Griff, ja.
Ja, aber mittlerweile haben sie irgendwie wahrscheinlich auch die hundertfache Zahl an Usern oder die tausendfache Tendenz steigend.
Ja, aber neue Features sind nicht wirklich hinzugekommen. Sie haben irgendwann mal diese Suchfunktion aufgekauft, die seitdem nicht mehr funktioniert. Und das ist wirklich furchtbar, diese Twitter-Suche ist unerträglich.
Ja gut, Twitter ist nochmal ein anderes Feld. An der Stelle, Tatsache ist, es wird versucht, neue Datenbankmodelle zu machen. Ich finde document-oriented den Ansatz an sich sehr gut und sollte sich feststellen, dass mit der CouchDB die Sache performant ist und dass man das mit modernen Webfremdwirk zusammenkriegt. Super, weil man will am Ende des Tages natürlich auch eine Objektorientierung haben.
Was ich natürlich noch mal sauspannend finde, das will ich mir noch mal demnächst angucken. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie jemand so einen quasi CouchDB in JavaScript geschrieben, sodass das funktioniert mit diesem ganzen HTML5-Storage-System. Weil mit HTML5 haben wir jetzt ja diese kleinseitige Datenbank und de de, es ist wieder eine SQL-Datenbank, die wir gerade eben gesagt nicht mehr haben wollen. Und das finde ich ist doch mein... Eskoleit. Und diesen Ansatz da quasi so eine CouchDB reinzupacken, damit ich nach außen hin als Entwickler das nur noch mit Dokumenten zu tun habe. Zum ersten und zum zweiten diese tollen Synchronisationsfähigkeiten. Nämlich, ich hab ein iPhone ab und ich bin online und dann holt er sich die Datenbank rein und alles ist schön. Und sobald ich offline bin, greift er auf meine lokale Datenbank zu und alle Änderungen werden synchronisiert, sobald ich das nächste Mal online bin.
Na Dennis, du hast keine Meinung dazu, wa?
Doch, aber ihr pauschalisiert zu stark.
Na dann kritisieren wir es doch mal.
Na, eure Dokumenten-based Datenbanken oder auch hier so Couch-DB hört sich irgendwie nach einem an, der halt nicht so ein riesen Oracle-Ding braucht oder halt dem es einfach zu viel ist, was ja auch verständlich ist. Und dann kommt halt so eine kleine DB und bringt es erstmal. Und dann sagst du schon, der hat keine User verwaltet. Und dann sehen sie, ach, das machen wir so und so. Aber wenn deine Ansprüche steigen, dann bist du ja doch ganz schnell wieder bei so einer vollblauen DB und ich meine, ich hab von Oracle nicht nur schlechtes gehört.
Ja, ich sag ja nicht, das wird es ablösen. Es ist für bestimmte Dinge dann einfacher zu benutzen. Ich meine, wenn du überschaubaren Storage hast.
Klar, wenn du weißt, du brauchst diesen Ding nicht.
Genau, sondern du hast nur viel kleines Krams, was sich immer mal wieder ändert. Und was du schnell mal im Zugriff haben willst, ohne gleich wieder so ein komplettes, meine SQL, AP-Implementierung muss irgendwie zwischengeladen werden, Nummer hast. Sondern dass du ganz einfach auf solche Webrequests runterbrechen kannst und dann einfach so einen hierarchischen Storage hast, der dann aber auch nicht langsam ist im Zugriff. Dann kann das schon eine Menge wert sein. Und wie gesagt, meine Erfahrung mit XSLT und XML ist einfach die, ich kann sehr einfach und vor allem eben auch sehr inkrementell meine Datenstrukturen ablegen und erstellen. Ich hab einfach so ein XML-Tri. Und wenn ich irgendeine, was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel in meinen Podcast-Datenbank noch für jede Episode die Lizenz noch ablegen will, derzeit steht das zwar irgendwo nicht so richtig, dann kann ich das halt einfach mit reinschreiben. Dann schreib ich da einfach License, irgendwie ID gleich sowieso und dann mach ich mir in irgendeiner anderen Stelle in diesem Dokument mach ich mir einfach eine List of Licenses, die eine ID haben und dann schmeiß ich es einfach mit rein. Und ich muss irgendwie nicht irgendwas ändern, keinen Schema, es ist einfach irgendwo mit drin und dadurch, dass es einen Pfad hat und für mich erreichbar ist, gibt's das. Und fertig. Und es ist sehr flexibel und ich kann jederzeit weitere Attribute da mit reinschreiben.
Du willst ja nicht neue Felder, irgendwie extra eine Datemark anmelden.
Genau. Und ich kann das auch hier reingespielte Schachten, was einfach in SQL nicht geht. Da muss ich da irgendwie komplexe Tabellenkonstruktionen, die sich einander referenzieren.
Da musst du auch immer erst die gesamten Listen einlesen und kannst nicht speziell nur die Lizenz mal rausholen. Also es geht bei deinem Fall halt noch, weil es relativ übersichtliche Datemark hat.
Ja gut, ich meine in dem Moment, wo ich eine Implementierung habe, die so einen Trieb performant ablegt und das ist das, was dieses KrautschDB Projekt zumindest verspricht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das hält. Das war, das mag ich aus, aber ich habe keine Erfahrung damit. Ja, also es gibt. Dann mag das eine tolle Sache sein, weil daran hat es halt bisher gehakt bei derzeitigen Ansätzen mit XML-Datenbanken. Aber hierarchical storage zu haben, das ist toll, weil das bietet mir SQL eben nicht, aber das ist tatsächlich, wie ich meist in meiner Information strukturiere. Wenn du runterbrichst, wie etwas strukturiert ist, dann kommst du ganz schnell in so eine Outline mit 3, 4, 5, 6 Verschachtelungen und wenn du dann irgendwas noch mal genauer spezifizieren willst, dann machst du da halt Klammer auf und hast halt noch mal ein Level, den du runterklappst. Und das kannst du halt in SQL, musst du das immer wieder auf dieses Flat-Table-Ding umrechnen mit IDs und Indirektionen und wenn irgendwas halt n-mal vorkommt, dann brauchst du noch mal ne Table und musst das immer wieder irgendwie joinen und inner joinen und du wirst total wahnsinnig, verstehst du das alles gar nicht und in der Dokumentendatenbank machst du halt einfach, naja, schreibst halt einfach hin und fertig.
Also man sitzt bei einer klassischen, also es gibt sicherlich Fälle, für die so klassische SQL-Datenbanken toll sind und man um Himmels willen nicht so eine Dokumentbasierte haben will. Aber ich wage jetzt einfach, ich schmeiß jetzt mal so eine Zahl in Raum, 90% aller Applikationen da draußen wären mit einem anderen Detailformat oder wären mit einer anderen Datenbankstruktur besser bedient. Und klar, ich geh auch mal davon aus, dass sowas wie CouchDB oder sowas rein von der Performance her, von der Abfragezeit pro Query schlechter da steht. Sie behaupten, dass einfach unglaublich viele Queries parallel können. Was MySQL ja nicht kann oder diese ganzen SQL-Datenbanken. Also dass die wohl ohne Probleme 5000 Query auf einen Schlag. Und dann, wenn das Ganze wirklich halbwegs skaliert und ich hab eben die entsprechenden Zugriffszahlen und dann stell ich mir einen zweiten Server daneben und ich brauch mal meine Datenbank zu replizieren und die halten sich hin und wieder mal untereinander schön aktuell ohne, dass ich große Probleme damit habe, dann stell ich im Zweifelsfall, Hardware kostet nicht die Welt, stell ich eben noch eine zweite Kiste daneben. Wenn ich eine große Maschine brauche, die plötzlich die dreifache Leistung und jetzt statt 8 GB 16 GB RAM braucht, das wird schon eher problematisch. Also ich glaube, es gibt sehr, sehr viele Fälle, in denen so eine Datenbank, in denen ich persönlich davon träum, einfach Daten schön schnell irgendwo reinschmeißen zu können. Und mir nicht mehr so mit Gedanken, um irgendwelche aufwendigen Strukturen machen zu müssen.
So, jetzt soll ich noch mal kurz Werbung machen.
Bitte.
Und zwar für Intel.
Ja, mach mal.
Und zwar ein Freund von mir hat sich ja den neuesten Mac Mini gekauft. Und hat sich dazu aber auch noch so eine Intel SSD bestellt. Weil er wollte es mal wissen. So eine 80 GB Platte.
Was kostet das?
Irgendwas zählt von 360 Euro oder so, also richtig Geld.
380 GB 360 Euro.
Kostet richtig Geld. Aber dann muss man erstmal diesen Mac Mini öffnen, das ist gar nicht so easy mit diesen Dingern halt. Muss mal ein bisschen gucken, wie es geht und so, dass man nichts kaputt macht.
Mit so einem Mörtel-Spachtel muss man da irgendwie reinstreichen.
Irgendwas Plaste, nicht so scharf, irgendwie am besten ein bisschen breiter, damit die Angriffsfläche nicht so auf so einen kleinen Punkt verteilt ist.
Spachtel, hab ich immer gehört, ist das beste.
Oder so ein Gitarrenplex oder irgendwas, wo du halt mit da so reinkommst. Weiß gar nicht, was wir da am Ende benutzt hatten. Egal. Teppichmesser war es nicht. Aber es ging. Das ganze Ding auseinandergebaut. Hatte sich auch gleich 4 GB Speicher reingemacht, anstatt das, was er da drin hatte. Und halt diese SSD-Platte. Und haben wir danach gestartet, das System installiert.
Er hat ihn schon vorher auch im Betrieb gehabt? Den Rechner und irgendwelche Daten?
Ne, wir haben den gleich sofort umgebaut.
Frisch gekauft und umgebaut?
Und klar, wir haben natürlich jetzt mit seinem alten Mac mini verglichen, den er hatte. Also er hatte sich den noch 2 Monate vorher, den letzten, geholt. Er wollte dann aber den neuen haben.
Wegen zweiten Bildschirm?
Ne, auch so, wegen schneller.
Und ist er auch nicht mehr so warm, oder?
Er hat nur auch das Gefühl, ganz bisschen kühler bleibt er. Jedenfalls diese SSD-Platte, es gibt ja dieses Featurem Finder, wo du sagst, du willst die Ordnergröße berechnet haben. Und wir haben geguckt bei dem alten Mac mini. Und ich meine, die Platte, keine Ahnung, was da drin war, aber so die CPU-Zeit spielt ja bei sowas eigentlich keine Rolle mehr, sondern nur so Plattenzugriff eigentlich. Und da siehst du richtig, wie er so klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, durch die eigenen einzelnen Ordner durchgeht und die Gewürze also zusammenrechnet. Wie wir es halt so kennen. Und bei dem mit dem SSD, alle auf einmal. Also es ist so ein Unterschied, das glaubst du nicht. Also es flutscht alles nur noch. Also wär mal richtig Bock auf, mal wieder einem Rechner so ein Speed-Bump geben, da wo du richtig mal was merkst, kann ich nur sagen, SSD ist so new shit.
Also bei ZvacBit war ich ja auf so einem, von diesem Sascha Palenberg heißt der glaube ich, der hier EPC News oder Mini-Netbook News macht. Der ist echt ein krasser Kerl. Der hat mittlerweile eine Zweitwohnung in Taiwan, weil er so oft da ist, um den neuesten Scheiß auszuprobieren. Und da waren auch die ganzen SSD-Junkies. Und da waren auch so 64 GB SSDs in diese kleinen Netbooks reinstecken. Und die Dinger gehen so ab, das ist unglaublich. Also das haben sie unter Windows gezeigt, so ein Windows XP dann drauf. Und dann alles, was im Startmenü ist, der Reihe nach anklicken und die Programme gehen auf.
Das hat er auch gemacht. Irgendwie die ganzen Programme einmal geklickt und da waren echt so Hoshis dabei wie Photoshop und so. Das hat nur so gemacht und dann waren die alle oben. Also wenn der Rechner, wenn einem das Mac OS X heutzutage langsam vorkommt, dann liegt es eigentlich glaube ich nur noch an der Platte.
Sind das diese Intel X25, Intel X18?
Genau.
Weißt du was das eine und was das andere ist?
Das eine ist eine Desktop-Version und das andere ist eine Laptop-Version wohl. Also dreieinhalb Zoll und zweieinhalb Zoll, wobei ja 1,8 und 2,5. Hört sich eher nach 1,8 Zoll und 2,5 Zoll, dann ist aber wohl nicht so.
Was war das jetzt für eine? Das war eine zweieinhalb Zoller. 80 Gigabyte, Intel X25M Mainstream, 400 Euro steht hier, 400 Euro.
Vielleicht hat er 400 bezahlt, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube die Mainstream sind noch ein bisschen langsamer als die Server-Versionen. Achso, dann gibt es noch die Extreme, die sind dann noch deutlich schneller.
Die sind noch deutlich teurer, 64 Gigabyte, 979 Euro.
Jetzt ist er aber wirklich der für Server.
2,5 Zoll Platten in Servern.
Klar, macht Sun auch. Die sind schneller, weil sie so schön klein ist. Die drehen dann mit richtig schnellen Umdrehungen.
Und da packst du außen Rationen dran.
Und wie schnell drehen die SSDs?
Gar nicht.
Das fand ich auch, wir hatten bei Spreele mal einen Sun-Server von denen zugeschickt. Bekomme so, hey.
Aber es rockt wie Sau. Und du hörst nichts mehr. Es ist einfach...
Also SSD ist der... Dieses Jahr wird das noch kommen.
Ja gut, aber die Kapazitäten sind noch nicht ganz so da, wo ich sie gerne hätte.
Die Preise sind noch nicht da, wo wir sie gerne hätten.
MacBook Air erste Generation ist ja mittlerweile dead-end. Also wer so ein MacBook Air erste Generation gekauft hat, hat echt ein Problem. Weil du kannst einfach da nicht mehr reinhauen als 80 GB.
Warum?
Weil das noch eine P-Arter-Platte ist und jetzt ist alles S-Arter und kein Mensch baut mehr große S-Arter.
Die haben da keinen S-Arter drin im ersten Air? Nein.
Aber da gibt es halt nichts und da wird es auch jetzt nichts mehr geben.
Naja, Abstoßen weiß ja nicht jeder. Jungs, schnell verkaufen.
Das Höchste, was du halt kriegen kannst, 1,8 Zoll, ist halt 160 Gigabyte. Das, was Apple halt auch bietet. 120 machen die, ne?
Die neuen jetzt, ja.
Hier gibt es einen 160er, aber die kostet halt auch 670 Euro.
Der hat sich halt vorher erkundigt und der meint, er hat mal sich so durchgelesen und die ganzen SSD von diesen anderen Herstellern, das wär alles irgendwie der Mumpitz und nur die von Intel in allen Tests würden die halt überlegen, gewinnen im Vergleich und dann wollte er das einfach mal haben und klar, es ist scheiße teuer und so, er wollte es aber mal wissen. Aber ich glaube, er bereut es nicht, auch für den Preis nicht, weil es ist echt wirklich, es geht ab wie nichts.
Es ist wie ein Prozessor-Upgrade, ne?
Ja, also es ist wie ein ganz anderer Rechner. Du kannst noch so einen lahmen Rechner nochmal, glaube ich, durch so eine schnelle Platte so richtig was rausholen. Weil es ist nicht die CPU, auf die wir hier warten, es sind die Daten, auf die wir warten.
Häufig, ja. Und RAM natürlich.
Aber die Platte ist halt noch langsamer.
Ja, aber der RAM entschärft das Thema ein bisschen.
Durch das Caching und so meinst du. Aber einmal musst du halt laden und so. Und wegspeichern auch. Und diese ganzen kleinen Reads, die du andauernd hast, also gerade auch bittere Nutzer, kann ich ja nur mal sagen, wo andauernd random Reads gemacht werden. Also mit einer SSD müsste das rocken wie nix.
Wie sieht es denn eigentlich im Stromverbrauch?
Ich glaube, der ist relativ gleich oder so ein bisschen knapp minimal weniger. Aber ist nicht so doll. Ich glaube, das wurde mal getestet und dann haben die dann herausgefunden, dass so eine SSD, wenn du sie richtig bepowerst und sie bringt ja dann aber auch mehr, dass sie dann sogar leicht mehr Strom verbraucht als eine Festplatte. Aber das machst du natürlich nicht die ganze Zeit. Du hast nicht die ganze Zeit 250 Megabyte die Sekunde auf deiner SSD. Das geht gar nicht.
Sodass es eigentlich Stromsparnender sein sollte, wenn du sie genauso wenig nutzt.
Aber ich glaube, so ein bisschen lohnt es sich doch noch zu warten, weil...
Klar, aber zu warten lohnt es sich immer.
Naja, aber auch bis die Betriebssystemunterstützung vernünftig ist.
Ich würde sagen fünf Jahre.
Nee, aber bis Snow Lappart auf jeden Fall. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie dann noch für eine SSD-Unterstützung kommen.
Aber was soll denn da für eine SSD-Unterstützung kommen? Ich weiß doch immer gar nicht, was die mit SSD-Unterstützung meinen.
Na ja, die meinen, ist das, was Windows eingebaut hat in Vista.
Was haben wir denn eingebaut?
Erklär doch erst mal, was die da eingebaut haben.
Na, diese, kann ich das gut erklären, dass du sozusagen nur so einen Cache darauf fährst. Dass du für die Platte sozusagen den Cache auf einem SSD fährst.
Ach so, für eine normale Platte.
Ja, für eine normale Platte. Davon ausgehen, dass du eben noch nicht die Kapazitäten hast, aber mittlerweile hat sich halt die Entwicklung auch schon so umgedreht.
Das ist auch der falsche Ansatz.
Ja, den hat ja Apple auch so nie verfolgt.
Man will da komplett umstellen.
Genau, Entschuldigung, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was das war. Es war nicht, dass du eine SSD-Platte als Cache für eine andere Platte nimmst, sondern dass du eine Platte mit einem SSD auf der Platte als Cache...
Na, das ist die eine Variante, die es gibt?
Wir haben wieder nicht komplett zu Ende gedacht, ne?
Was weiß ich?
Ich finde das als Zwischenlösung übrigens gar nicht schlecht, dass man so quasi das Betriebssystem auf irgendwie 32 Gig oder so was rumliegen hat, dann liegt die MP3-Sammlung auf den restlichen 500 Gigabyte. Finde ich nicht, dass irgendwas dagegen spricht.
Wir machen ja die neuen XSurf, ne? Die neuen XSurf haben ja als Option eine SSD-Platte, die keinen Slot wegnimmt.
Genau, die einfach so drin ist. Brauchen wir ja auch nicht. Die sollten einfach 20 oder 32 Gig direkt aus dem Wasserboard kleben, von diesem SSD-Zeug.
Das ist wohl schon noch so eine Platte, so eine 1.8 oder so, die du da halt irgendwo noch mit reinschieben kannst. Und dann hast du trotzdem vorne noch die drei Traces, die halt so richtig mit Platten und rotieren.
Aber das nächste Thema ist natürlich, dass aktuelle Betriebssysteme sind darauf optimiert, dass du die Zugriffszeiten möglichst kurz hältst, dass du nicht so große Kopfbewegungen machst auf der Platte. Und dafür ist ein spezieller Cache drin, den zum Beispiel auch Mac OS X anlegt, dass die Daten möglichst schön an einem Stück gelesen werden können. Das sind so Punkte, die bei einer SSD-Platte nicht mehr so ins Gewicht fallen. Im Gegenteil, da will man die Daten unter Umständen sogar möglichst weit über die Platte verteilen. Damit immer unterschiedliche...
Das macht ja die SSD-Platte selbst dieses Verteilen.
Naja, das kriegen die aber teilweise, wenn die Betriebssysteme die Daten falsch anliefern, beziehungsweise wenn die... Also die Betriebssysteme probieren da schon eine gewisse eigene Intelligenz reinzulegen und die Platten können das noch nicht nach Belieben ausgleichen sozusagen.
Du meinst, das Support für SSD ist das eigentlich, dass man diese fälschlichen Optimierungen jetzt langsam wieder rausnimmt?
Dass man die langsam rausnimmt und wahrscheinlich neue Optimierungen für SSD einbaut, die sich überhaupt erst mal noch finden müssen. Ich glaube, da müssen noch neue Ideen gefunden werden.
Aber ich denke, an Snow Leopard kommt für SSD Support jetzt nichts Spezielles. Glaub ich nicht.
Das glaub ich auch nicht.
Na irgendwann müssen sie kommen. Also ich meine, sie verkaufen jetzt schon seit ein Jahrzeiten Rechner mit SSD-Platte und...
Na was sollen sie da großes supporten? Also ich sehe da jetzt nicht so viel, was sie da supporten müssen.
Also wie gesagt, diese Platte mit... Ich hab 32 GB Flash und 500 GB klassische Festplatte, damit es halbwegs bezahlbar ist, aber trotzdem schön schnell, finde ich schick.
Also zu dem Thema kann ich euch auch nochmal verweisen auf eine Chaos-Radio-Sendung. Ausnahmsweise nicht Chaos-Radio Express, und zwar die letzte.
Richtig.
Ja, weil Vic hat sich da nochmal so zum Thema Datenrettung geäußert und da gab es dann irgendwann am zweiten Tag, glaube ich, auch nochmal so eine ausführliche Darstellung genau dieser Problematik, dass die Platten heutzutage schon so viel Optimierungen machen und das gilt insbesondere dann auch für Flash-Platten, dass eben so dieses Daten-Retten und Wiederfinden bzw. das Löschen von Daten, genau darum ging es nämlich in dem Moment, dass das Löschen von Daten sehr schwierig ist. Zum Beispiel kannst du auf eine SSD einfach keine Daten überschreiben, weil die flüchten sich dann immer wieder in irgendeinen anderen Sektor und du hast überhaupt keine Kontrolle mehr darüber. Aber der Teil, den fand ich sehr informativ im Bezug darauf, wie viel Eigenintelligenz Platten mittlerweile mitbringen und wie schwer sich das Vorhersagen, und das geschweigene Optimieren von Betriebssystemseite her. Also da ist, glaube ich, Hopfen und Malz verloren. Von deswegen denke ich auch nicht, dass da viel kommen wird. Der Chat postet hier einen Blog-Eintrag. Den werden wir jetzt aber nicht lesen, oder? Ja, wie auch immer.
Ich habe mir noch jetzt mal...
Haben wir noch Themenkarten?
Ich habe noch eine, die ich noch so im Ärmel hätte und zwar wir haben ja immer dieses Router-Problem noch. Time Capsule, genau. Ich bin ja da so ein AVM-Freund. Und Fritzer. Und habe mir jetzt noch eine Fritzbox geholt. Also ich bin relativ...
Welche komplizierte Zahl steht dahinter?
7270.
Das kann man sich ja gut merken.
Das kann man sich super merken. Ich glaube, das ist das aktuelle Top-Modell. Ich hoffe es zumindest.
Ich finde, dass man Marketing-Leute, die solche Produkte mit Zahlen einfallen lassen, die sollte man einfach feuern. Einfach feuern. Wenn sie fragen, nicht nur feuern, sondern auch noch ihren Schreibtisch fair feuern.
Aber die Marketing-Leute bei denen mögen nicht so der Hammer sein, aber sie haben ziemlich gute Ingenieure.
Wieso nennen sie ihn nicht 73,47-Periode?
Weil das so schlecht auf die Verpackung draufpasst.
Ach so, weil es ist zu lang. Die haben auf ihrem Windows-Rechner diesen Strich nicht in ihrem Font, den man dann über die Zahl setzt.
Nee, aber das ist...
Okay, was macht die tolle Fritzbox?
Die tolle Fritzbox, sie hat...
Bügelt. Ist das so ein Teil, was auch deckt hat? Ja, was hat auch deckt?
Also Telefonanlage hatte schon die Alte. Ich hatte so eine Fritzbox-Phone-WLAN, hieß das Ding, mit der man Internet-Telefonie machen kann. Also die hatten eine ISDN-Anlage drin. Das ging schon bei der Alten wie gesagt. Man konnte ISDN-Telefone anschließen und konnte die an einem ganz normalen, analogen Telefonanschluss betreiben. Und so dieses ganze Makeln und Händeln und weiß der Teufel was, was so alles geht, über deckt und über ISDN, diese ganzen Konformat- Merkmale konnte das. Jetzt hat es noch so eine...
Musstest du dafür selber das Internet machen oder kann das auch einen anderen Internet-Router benutzen? Also kann man das auch wirklich so als Telefonanlage benutzen? Das könnte man auch als Telefonanlage benutzen.
Also man kann die DSL-Funktionalität explizit abschalten und das einfach als IP-Buchse reinhängen ins Netz. Ja, wie gesagt, es hat eine Deckbasis-Station drinne. Das lässt sich auch alles relativ unkompliziert einrichten. Es hat einen USB-Anschluss, an dem man mit einer... wo man zum Beispiel eine Festplatte anschließen kann und dann kann man die per SMB und per FDP... So eine Nass-Funktionalität, die will ich noch mal ein bisschen auschecken, was die überhaupt kann. Aber ansonsten finde ich das schon mal eine sehr spannende Sache, dass man da so eine kleine Fritz-Box hat.
Kann aber kein Web-DAV.
In einer Labor-Version der Firmware kann es das.
Das heißt, man kann das Ding über HTTP mounten?
Man kann das dann. Den Teil habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ja, ohne mich zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen zu wollen, das geht. Guck nochmal nach auf der Labor-Seite. Du willst nicht SMB?
Ich will nicht SMB.
Und was kann hier noch alles? Achso, die kann Endstandard, was ich unbedingt haben wollte. Also ich hatte vorher eben diese ganz normale mit, wie viel war das vorher? Welcher Buchstabe war da dran? Und das war mir zu langsam und das hat mir zu viele Probleme bereitet. Darum habe ich mir noch irgendwann von Belkin so einen zweiten Router daneben gestellt. Und das Ding war einfach immer totaler Scheiße. Also Belkin kann vielleicht ganz hübsche iPod-Zubehörsachen bauen, aber ihre Router sind wirklich Schrott. Und jetzt habe ich da mit dieser Fritzbox, also die hat definitiv auch eine höhere Reichweite als dieser Belkin-Router, als ich jemals hatte. Das hat schon irgendwie, das hat irgendwas sehr Solides. Und was noch eine hübsche Sache ist, das Ganze, da läuft der Linux drauf auf dieser Fritzbox. Und da gibt es eine relativ aktive Entwickler-Gemeinde.
Kann es den NUT-PMP?
NUT-PMP, das ist dieses Plug & Play oder was ist das?
Nee, das ist nicht Plug & Play, das ist nicht Microsoft, sondern Apple.
Achso, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, wie kommt dein bitteren Klein nach draußen so?
Indem ich die Portsfrage gegeben habe, weil ich sowas gerne, über sowas gerne den Daumen draufhege.
Mit irgendwie IP-Adresse fest eintragen für deinen Teil und so.
Genau.
Das ist anstrengend. Und wenn jemand anders dann zu Besuch ist, dann muss er ja auch...
Dann macht er eben keinen bitteren für den Moment.
Aha, na Dennis wird dich nie besuchen können.
Nein, aber es gibt da eine relativ aktive Entwicklergemeinde, die entwickelt eine Erweiterung eigentlich mehr. Das ist gar nicht wirklich ein neues Betriebssystem, weil die setzen auch auf den Betriebssystem von AVM auf, auf diesen Linux. Und dazu wird hinzugefügt Freats, also wie Fritz bloß mit E für Freiheit. Und da gibt es echt eine schöne Auswahl an Programmen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel, was ich ja immer schmerzlich vermisse bei so Billig-Routern oder Home-Routern, einen kleinen DNS-Server, der da drin steckt, sodass man einfach mal relativ entspannt ein paar Domain-Namen hinzufügen kann für das interne Netz, ohne gleich hier ein großartiges Tra-La-La machen zu müssen.
Kann man auch gleich Zensursula mit umgehen?
Fritz-Router gegen Zensursula.
Haben ihre Router auch einen Anti-Zensur-Filter?
VPN können sie, aber leider erst mal nur über ein fritzeigenes Protokoll, aber dank Erweiterung über Open Source auch OpenVPN zum Beispiel.
Man kann einen aber nicht pptp irgendwie automatisch...
OpenVPN ist das, das müsste pptp sein, glaube ich. Also mit OpenVPN habe ich auf jeden Fall mal auf dem Mac eine schöne Verbindung hergestellt.
Das hätte ich ja auch ganz gerne in meinem Router, dass ich gleich bei SwissVPN mich einfach bei Default einlogge, dass ich ein Paket rausgebe.
Es gibt unglaublich viel. Es gibt Transmission auf der Fritzbox. Läuft bei mir allerdings noch nicht so gut. Also das ist hier dieser sehr beliebte BitTorrent-Client. Und ich meine, das ist dann schon eine lustige Variante, wenn man dann so eine externe Festplatte an einandersteilt. Du packst da ein BitTorrent-Client drauf.
Steuerst den übers Web?
Steuerst den übers Web. Und das Ganze mit irgendwie 5 Watt aus deiner blöden kleinen Fritzbox.
Und guckst den Film dann übers Netz, weil liegt ja dort auf der Platte.
Wenn ich klicken muss, sehe ich.
Ich glaube, vorhin irgendwie mit ihrer 2.0-Version haben wir jetzt auch so BitTorrent und so weiter.
Das wäre die Eier legenden Wollmesswolle. Also ganz doll dick. Also Apple schiebt da auch schon mehr rein. Noch nicht ganz so viel wie jetzt Fritzbox oder so, aber auch schon.
Genau, jetzt warten wir da drauf, dass Apple jetzt auch BitTorrent einschaltet auf der Time-Capsule. Freak ist es auch mal, würde ich sagen, wenn das passiert.
Das wird dann passieren, wenn sie, du hast ja schon gesagt, dass Apple TV ist ja ein OS X drauf, dass wenn vielleicht auf der nächsten Airport Express auch ein OS X drauf ist, dann kann man das ja schon mal aufbohren.
Ja, aufbohren. Ich glaub ja noch nicht so dran, dass Apple jemals BitTorrent einbauen wird. Also sie werden es zumindest nicht tun, bevor es nicht irgendeinen Standard gibt. Gibt es da eigentlich irgendwelche Bestrebungen, da mal einen RFC draus zu machen, aus dem ganzen Kram?
Weiß ich nicht. Seitdem die da Company sind bei BitTorrent Inc. bringt ja da keiner mehr durch.
Das muss ja nicht BitTorrent machen, das muss ja irgendjemand anders machen. Ich meine, RFC kannst du schreiben, kann ich machen.
Okay, das darfst du dann nicht BitTorrent nennen.
Ist ja egal, kannst du ja irgendwie nennen, kannst ja Faseldrönen nennen.
Ich finde, das wäre ja langsam mal Zeit für ein peer-to-peer Web.
Pirate-to-Pirate-Protokoll.
Ja, glaub ich noch keiner gemacht, bin mir aber nicht so sicher.
Aber das würde extrem helfen, dass man diese ganzen Sachen mal wirklich in so ein Internetstandard gießt, weil ich meine, wenn 50% des Internet-Treffings mit diesem Protokoll laufen, wäre es ja vielleicht mal ganz angemessen, diesen Protokoll-Treffing auch mal zu dokumentieren. Weil derzeit dokumentiert sich das halt einfach nur über Source Code in Clients. Und das geht nicht.
Und bei BitTorrent Org. Aber das ist da so bürokratisch, da macht es keinen Spaß irgendwelche Vorschläge zu machen.
Da steht tatsächlich eine Doku?
Klar, sonst würde doch gar nichts funktionieren.
Das funktioniert ja so schon kaum. Ja eben, ich dachte die Standards wären jetzt im Wesentlichen von Pirate Bay gesetzt. Sind die Jungs eigentlich noch, die laufen noch rum, ne? Die sind auch nach wie vor guter Laune?
Ich hab ja gehört, der hält vielleicht eine keynote auf der Siegend. Hab ich das jetzt gesagt?
Makroppen.
Vielleicht.
Dürfen die auch aus dem Land ja, die sind ja noch nicht verurteilt.
Die sind verurteilt. Sie sind schon in Berufe gegangen und sie bitten darum, keine Spenden zu schicken, weil sie werden keine Gebühren, Strafgebühren oder was auch immer bezahlen. Das heißt, sie wollen gar kein Geld haben, weil es nur zur Not verschwinden könnte und das wollen sie gar nicht. Also nichts, spenden. Die wollen arm bleiben. Absichtlich. Macht ja auch Sinn. Also die gehen da richtig so hardcore, da laufen die gegen die Wand oder auch brechen durch. Mal gucken.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Jungs da irgendwie, die sind echt die Definition of hardcore. Oder? Also Peter und die Bande, ich meine, ich teile nicht unbedingt jede Ansicht, die sie so vertreten, finde allerdings ihre Konsequenz bewundernswert und in der Hinsicht auch schon wieder, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht so richtig, was ich davon halten soll, aber so ist es. Sie stehen halt auf diesem Standpunkt, dass der ganze Copyright-Kram für sie einfach nicht gilt, weil es in 100 Jahren sowieso ausgestorben ist. Und gut, da kann man halt jetzt der und der Meinung sein. Und sie ziehen es einfach echt gnadenlos durch. Ich bin bloß gespannt, wie das Land Schweden so gedenkt mit ihnen umzugehen.
Es wird noch auch interessant. Und ich glaube, das wird auch noch irgendwie diese Copyright-Problematik. Ich denke mal, da wird sich die Welt noch bestimmt 10, 20 Jahre mit beschäftigen. Das Netz wird echt immer größer, immer schneller. Vor ein paar Jahren hat so ein Film noch einen Tag gedauert. Inzwischen ist es echt, der ist schneller da, als du ihn gucken kannst eigentlich. Und wie soll es erstmal sein, wenn so ein Film, du klickst und er ist sofort da? Wer soll das alles denn protokollieren? Du kannst einfach alle Filme runterladen, die es dann so gibt, oder jeden Stuff, oder was auch immer. Also das kann man einfach glaube ich nicht mehr kontrollieren. Das geht dann unter auch in dem Traffic, der dann demnächst stattfinden wird.
Da müssen einfach neue Geschäftsmodelle her. Das ist, ähm, das fand ich ja...
Die beinhalten kein Copyright.
Die beinhalten kein Copyright. Also ich meine, das ist albern. Das ist, selbst, dieses YouTube-Video, das kursierte von Dieter Bohlen, wie er ich glaube bei irgendeinem öffentlich-rechtlichen Talk, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Beckmann oder dem anderen rumsaß.
Der Clip von Bohlen, wo er meinte, das wäre doch alles.
Ey, also wirklich so, so, so. Dieter Bohlen, also ich meine, den man nicht für einen Idioten hält, aber wo man sich so denkt. Offensichtlich nicht, weil der sich da hingesetzt hat und gesagt hat, ey, das ist so durch das Thema.
Ich hab das gesehen, der hat wirklich sehr kluge Dinge gesagt. Das hat mich sehr überrascht. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass er so kluge Sachen sagen kann.
Du meinst also, er ist eigentlich so ein Arsch, so vom Verhalten her, aber er ist nicht doof. Aber er ist nicht doof.
Genau.
Er ist ja auch ein Geschäftemacher-Typ, oder?
Der ist nicht doof. Er ist ein Arschloch, aber er ist nicht doof. Er ist nicht doof. Wie die meisten Arschlöcher meistens.
Er weiß, dass das Geschäftsmodell, mit dem er in den 80er Jahren Geld gemacht hat, dass er damit heute kein Geld mehr machen kann und das auch nie wieder tun können wird, das hat er eigentlich relativ deutlich gesagt und es auch gar nicht vor hat.
Ja, und dann auch so, wir haben da früher irgendwie auch kopiert und wir saßen da irgendwie neben unserem Bandlaufwerk und mit Überspielkabel und tralala und irgendwie, was machen denn die Kids heute anderes und die dazu kriminalisieren, das wär alles Quatsch. Sehr interessanter Clip.
Ja, den hätte man dann mal neben dem Mode oder wie heißt es, setzen müssen auf dieser Veranstaltung damals.
Ja, also ich meine, ich finde ja nun dieses, man darf jetzt jedermanns Content-Erzeugnis nehmen und sein Business-Modell beliebig zu zerstören, wie man das für richtig hält, finde ich auch nicht so ohne weiteres haltbar. Ja, also was weiß ich, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel auch mit Podcasts versucht, sein Überleben zu gestalten, wie ich das zum Beispiel auch mache. Da muss natürlich jeder so seinen Weg finden. Und mein Weg, den ich da habe, ist derzeit im Wesentlichen auch einer, der auf Free Content setzt, der mir bezahlt wird dafür, dass ich ihn mache. Aber das ist nicht unbedingt immer machbar. Also du findest nicht immer irgendjemand, der dir Geld dafür gibt, dass du es machst. Und ich denke auch nicht alles, was du machst, kann durch Spenden oder ähnliche generöse Grundmodelle getragen werden. Manche Formate schon. Aber wenn man jetzt wirklich sowas macht wie Tutorials zum Beispiel, so E-Learning-Kram, was durchaus ein Punkt ist. Und dein Modell ist halt, dass du dir den sozusagen abkaufen lässt per User, der ihn sozusagen konsumiert, weil er ja einen Wert davon hat. Und dann kommt halt irgendjemand und wirft es halt einfach ins Netz. Und dein ganzes Basis ist weg. Und dann ist das einzige Argument mit, na ja, so ist die Welt halt. Man kann ja jetzt alles kopieren und deswegen machen wir das auch. Da frage ich mich, wo da die Legitimation des Handelns ist an der Stelle an.
Ja, vielleicht ist ja der Fluch des dritten Jahrtausends, dass halt die Ware totale ist.
Ja, das gilt genauso auch für Hollywood. Ich meine, man kann die jetzt mögen oder nicht mögen. Aber Tatsache ist, dass sie halt eine ganze Menge Energie reinstecken in die Produktion dieser Dinger. Und die gefällt ja offensichtlich den Leuten auch, die sich das anschauen. Sonst würde ja die Ware nicht so heiß gehandelt werden. Und was ist jetzt die Argumentation, den Leuten das Geld für ihre Arbeit vorzuenthalten? Also an der Stelle finde ich, stockt die ganze Copyright-Diskussion und wird auch irgendwie ein bisschen bekloppt geführt.
Naja, ich glaube nicht, dass man so ein Grundrecht hat, sich alles zu kopieren, was irgendwie kopierbar ist. Das ist, das halte ich auch für falsch, sondern es wird...
Pirate Bay macht es aber so.
Ja klar, die gehen einen sehr, sehr radikalen Weg. Und ich finde, dass es das Ziel sollte sein, oder dass es wahrscheinlich darauf hinausläufen muss, da einen neuen Konsens auszuhandeln. Und erstmal hat die Musikindustrie ja damit angefangen. Erst mal haben sie ganz große Panik geschoben vor MP3s. Und dann haben sie irgendwie auch mitgekriegt, na Moment mal, da kann man aber auch eine Menge durchdrücken. Da kann man plötzlich DRM drauf packen, und dann kann man kontrollieren, wie oft wird das abgespielt. Dann kann man vielleicht ums die Modelle ausdenken und die Modelle ausdenken. Dann kann man Pro-Hören abkassieren. Und der Versuch ist offensichtlich in Sachen Musikindustrie erstmal gescheitert, würde ich sagen. Zumindest vorübergehend. Also DRM im Musikbereich, im Musikkaufbereich ist tot.
Ja, aber das liegt vor allem daran, dass es Ihnen schon vorher, weil Sie es schon mal ohne DRM gemacht haben, und sozusagen ohne DRM dasselbe Produkt anbieten auf CDs. Und natürlich auch in der Art und Weise, wie dieser Content konsumiert wird, weil das etwas ist, was man immer mal wieder hört, während es eben schon Sachen gibt, die eben ein oder höchstens zweimal konsumiert werden und danach sind sie eigentlich Wegwerfware.
Naja, aber nehmen wir doch mal so Sachen wie zum Beispiel so amerikanische Serien wie South Park, kann ich mir ja nun Probleme über das Netz angucken. Also legal mein ich, legal natürlich sowieso, da gibt's ja eh alles, aber oder The Daily Show kann man sich auch legal angucken und ich jetzt die Möglichkeit, das illegal zu tun, in dem Fall Pirate Bay oder wo auch immer runter lade. Also per BitTorrent. Oder eben indem ich auf die Webseite gehe und es da genau so tue. Und bei South Park ehrlich gesagt noch nicht, aber bei The Daily Show gucke ich mittlerweile über die Webseite an, weil mich stört dieser eine Werbeclip, der da im Augenblick dazwischen kommt, noch nicht. Und es ist einfach bequem und ich hab eben das Gefühl, naja, dann kriegen die eben sogar noch dadurch, dass sie diesen Werbeclip sehen, verdienen sie noch ein bisschen Geld dran. Und es ist ja auch in meinem Interesse, dass die ihr Geld verdienen. Es muss bloß einfach ein neuer Deal rausgehandelt werden, ein Stück weit.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt gerade mit der Webseite überhaupt nicht glücklich bin.
Ich bin damit nicht perfekt glücklich.
Sie machen halt nur Streaming. Hast du eine langsame Verbindung, kannst du das nicht sehen?
Ja, ich weiß, du magst Streaming nicht, sondern nicht ich.
Den Streit hatten wir schon.
Den Streit hatten wir schon, brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Für meine Bedürfnisse ist es okay. Damit nutze ich es darüber. Ich will gar nicht immer alles hören. Dafür fängt es auch sofort an zu spielen, wenn ich drauf klicke. Das ist auch was wert. Und insofern, ja und bei South Park kann man sich die ganzen Clips runterladen. Wenn die entsprechenden Angebote gemacht werden, dann bin ich auch bereit, die zu nutzen. Wahrscheinlich wird einfach dieses Wegfallen, was früher war, dass eben die Wahlbestand zwischen, wenn das Geschäftsmodell schlecht ist, dann konsumiere ich es eben gar nicht, wird hinten laufen zu, wenn das Geschäftsmodell schlecht ist, dann besorge ich den Zensursuch.
Mit diesen Geschäftsmodellen, das ist natürlich so das eine. Und den Leuten irgendwie vorzuwerfen, dass sie nicht das Richtige haben, gut, das mag ja sein, dass sie nicht die richtige Antwort gefunden haben auf die Realität, dass Dinge kopiert werden. Aber eine Welt, in der alles sozusagen automatisiert, beliebig verbreitet wird, ist halt irgendwo unfair.
Unfair nach unserer bisherigen Denke.
Den Leuten gegenüber, die Mehrwert halt in Content, in kopierfähigem Gut schaffen.
Naja, den schaffen gar nicht mal unbedingt so. Weil, also ich hab jetzt...
Warum? Wir schaffen doch hier auch irgendwie...
Naja, aber guck mal, wir haben zum Beispiel diesen... Im Augenblick beschweren sich ja richtig lautstark eigentlich nur die, die bisher für die Duplizierung des Contents zuständig waren. Und das waren auch die, die wirklich damit Geld verdient haben. Wir haben ja diese ganze Open Access-Diskussion im Augenblick sehr stark, dass Wissenschaftler Content erzeugen. Und es sind ja gar nicht die Wissenschaftler, die sich gegen Open Access wehren. Im Gegenteil, die stützen es ja größtenteils. Sondern wehren sich dagegen, weil die ihr Geschäftsmodell flöten gehen sehen, ist die Verlage, die sich damit beschäftigt haben, diesen zu duplicieren.
Im Falle von Hollywood ist es nicht so.
Im Falle von Hollywood ist es nicht so. Aber falls mir gerade besser ein Kram passt, bleib ich erst mal kurz bei dem Beispiel.
Hollywood ist das, was wirklich in der Diskussion ist. Und das ist auch das, wo ich glaube, wo gerade auch wirklich der Dissens herrscht. Ich meine, was ist, wenn niemand mehr ins Kino geht? Vielleicht geht ja nicht niemand jemand mehr ins Kino. Oder niemand leidet sichs. Also angenommen, du könntest jetzt über deine Fritzbox hättest du sozusagen auch noch gleich automatisch nicht nur deinen Betonklein eingebaut, sondern auch noch so den mit hol dir den RSS-Feed der aktuellen Hollywood-Movies, die gerade geraubt im Netz rum sind und dann streamst du den direkt auf den Fernseher. Und du würdest dieses Produkt so verkaufen in Deutschland. Es würde weggehen wie warme Semmel. Und es würde dazu führen, dass irgendwie ein Apple TV nicht funktioniert.
Es würde dazu führen, dass ein Apple TV nicht funktioniert.
Weil du kriegst sozusagen dasselbe in schneller und in höher weiter und in billiger und Flatrate, der ganze Hollywood-Content kostenlos. Damit wäre sozusagen der Verleihmarkt für Filme in Deutschland tot.
Nee, das sag ich nicht. Man muss halt ein besseres Angebot machen.
Ja, aber was sollte denn bitte ein besseres Angebot sein als kostenlos? Bessere Qualität sofort.
Zuverlässiger?
Unbeschränkt alles.
Ich meine, bessere Qualität als die Raubkopierte geschickt.
Genau, zuverlässiger ist glaube ich so ein ganz wichtiges Thema, weil bei BitTorrent wie oft hat man da mal so eine dämliche WMV-Datei drin, die der eigentlich probiert nur irgendwie über einen RSS-Feeds mit irgendwie die beste Version in einem definierten Format.
Dann ist das genauso gut. Und dann ist es vor allem auch gut genug.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube da müssen neue Modelle heran und ich glaube die werden gefunden werden. Da fand ich ja den Vortrag von Corridctoral of the Republica sehr inspirierend. Der meinte vor 100 Jahren war das eben so, dass vor 100 Jahren Leute, die sind Künstler, die haben Musik gemacht und die haben sich in den Raum gestellt und haben gesagt jeder, der uns hier hören will, da vorne ist eine Tür, kommt rein und da müsst ihr dem Typen Geld in die Hand drücken.
Das geht aber mit Kinofilmen nicht.
Und plötzlich hat irgendjemand angefangen, diesen Leuten ein Mikrofon vor die Nase zu setzen und zu sagen und wir strahlen das Ganze jetzt aus. Übrigens, dein Geschäftsmodell ist jetzt flöten, weil dir packen wir einfach so ein Mikrofon vor die Fresse und das hat man am Radio genannt und da konnte das plötzlich jeder empfangen einfach so und dann musste ein neues Geschäftsmodell entstehen, da mussten sich die Künstler anpassen und haben sich dieser neuen Technik dann ja im Endeffekt auch stellen müssen sozusagen. Und jetzt ist eben die Umbrustsituation da, wo möglicherweise dieses alte Radio-Geschäftsmodell nicht mehr funktioniert. Das war seine Aussage, die fand ich ganz spannend in dem Moment. Und da wird sich sicherlich, das wird nicht der Heilige Graf für alle werden und das wird nicht die große neue Freiheit sein und wir werden natürlich unseren Content auch in Zukunft bezahlen müssen. Aber vielleicht haben wir ein bisschen mehr Kontrolle darüber, wo das hingeht oder es ist für uns ein bisschen transparenter, wo es hingeht. Und eine Menge dazwischen durch kann man auch, wie gesagt gerade im Bereich Buchmarkt, wo Verlage wirklich nur dafür die Hand aufhalten, dass sie die Druckmaschine anstellen.
Das ist nicht so.
Na ja, ganz so ist es nicht, aber es ist...
Verlag macht, um ein Buch rauszubringen, mehr als Seiten zu drücken.
Also ich hatte mit Wissenschaftsverlagen zu tun, die halten vorher nochmal die Hand auf, bevor sie das drucken. Die kriegen da ihren Druckkostenzuschuss und du musst denen druckfertige PDF-Dokumente abliefern heutzutage.
Ist so.
Also ich hab's wirklich...
Das war nicht die Verlage, die ich meinte, aber das mag...
Anerkannte Fachbuchverlage, das ist so. Und das mag bei irgendwelchen populären Titeln, also Harry Potter, klar, die JK. Rowling, die braucht sich wahrscheinlich keine Sorgen darum zu machen, dass sie nachher einen PDF da abliefern muss, was auch... und ansonsten wird sich um die Ohren gehauen. Aber das war eben auch, schon wie auf der Republika hat ja dieser, wie heißt der von Texter der Mensch?
Steini? Steini? Oder Christopher?
Ich weiß nicht, wer auf der Republika da war.
Ich weiß nicht, der heißt, der war... Ich und mein Namensgedächtnis, das ist echt doof. Der hat so ein bisschen erzählt und der hat...
War mit französischem Akzent, da war es Christopher, ansonsten war es Steini.
Dann war es Steini. So ein kleiner war... Steini. Egal. Auf jeden Fall hat der mal so eine kleine Rechnung aufgemacht. Und zwar, in Deutschland gilt man wohl ab 20.000 verkauften Buchexemplaren als Bestseller. Und so, was macht man an so einem durchschnittlichen Buch als Autor? So 90 Cent bis ein Euro. Das heißt, wenn du einen Bestseller hingelegt hast, hast du davon, und nehmen wir mal an, du hast auch ein Jahr gesessen, hast du so 15.000 bis 20.000 Euro gemacht. Das ist...
Wenig für ein Jahr.
Das ist für einen fucking Bestseller. Wie viele Autoren kriegen kein Bestseller hin? Und er meinte, wir sollten nicht länger so tun, gerade im Buchbereich, als ob man von Bücherschreiben leben könnte. Also es gibt bestimmt Leute, die von Büchern leben können, aber nicht die Mehrzahl der Autoren.
Und das ist mit der Musik eigentlich auch so, oder? Es gibt ja nur ein paar, die richtig verdienen und ganz ganz viele nicht.
Und das ist mit der Musik wahrscheinlich ähnlich. Oder genau das Gleiche. Vielleicht finden wir da ja irgendwie was besseres. Und das heißt nicht, dass jeder Künstler davon ja zwangsläufig leben können muss, von dem, was er da produziert. Aber wenn er zwischendurch eine Schicht wegfällt, die sich der Hälfte der Gewinne einstreicht und...
Er kann aber schon von einer Tätigkeit leben, wenn er ein Network-Mensch ist. Da kann man vielleicht mal ein Buch schreiben. Ein Buch hat ja auch noch andere Effekte, außer nur, dass es gekauft wird, sondern es wird ja auch gelesen. Man führt dann sozusagen auch dazu, dass man da mit einem gewissen Ruhm und Ehre und Bekanntheitsgrad und Experten... Genau, schreibt man mal ein Buch drüber.
Das nennen wir dann, wir nennen das Arbeit und du machst dir eine lustige Frisur.
Gut, lass uns die Copyright-Debatte verlassen.
Jetzt haben wir nicht über iPhone geredet, sondern nur über sonstige megafreunde Themen. Auch sehr schön, finde ich ja.
Ich finde, sie müssen noch über Snow Leopard reden.
Ja, ich hab...
Immer hat er befürchtende, wie sagt man, beunruhigende Nachrichten gehört.
Ich hab, na wir haben also ein Vögelchen hat zu mir gezwitschert. Gezwittert? Nügend anderes Vögelchen. Ich hab gehört, dass die letzte Snow Leopard Beta, die so verteilt wurde...
Die 10A335 von letzten Donnerstag?
Keine Ahnung, das kann sein, dass es die war. Ich hab nur gehört mit die letzte und ich weiß jetzt schon nicht mehr genau, ob das irgendwie ein, zwei oder drei Wochen her ist, dass ich das gehört habe. Doch drei Wochen kann es nicht sein, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es ein oder zwei Wochen, wie auch immer auf jeden Fall.
Also muss es die vorletzte sein.
Ich weiß es nicht. Habe diese Version in der Client Version, also Mac OS X Client wohlgemerkt, nicht Server, kein ZFS mehr drin. Hab ich gehört. Mehr weiß ich nicht.
Das geht ja ganz easy. Wir sind ja im Irk vertreten. Das, was du meinst, kann ja eigentlich nur die Version 10A314 sein, weil die andere kam erst letzten Donnerstag. Und da soll doch mal bitte jemand testen, wir nennen doch seinen Namen nicht, ob da irgendwie eine ZFS Kernel Extension in der Client Version von 10A314 drin ist. Weil in einer 10A286, da ist die definitiv drin. Und in der ganzen neuen 10A335, ich kenne noch keinen, der die irgendwie hätte. Und denen können die das uns ja mal stecken irgendwie. Ist ja nicht so schwer, Jungs. Na ja, wäre schon interessant zu wissen.
Was auch immer das bedeuten mag. Ich meine, das kann sein, dass sie gerade ein Problem damit haben und uns irgendwie nicht schippen konnten. Und später kommt es da wieder rein.
Dann hätten sie die alte genommen, glaube ich.
Na vielleicht haben sie irgendeinen anderen Teil des Kernels angefasst, wo irgendwie keine Version mehr damit lief.
Kann sein. Also in der 10A286, höre ich gerade, ist noch ZFS drin.
Das war jetzt aber die Vorletzte, nicht die Letzte.
Das war die Vorvorletzte.
Vorvorletzte.
Ja, letzten Donnerstag gibt es eine neue.
Okay, verstehe.
Und da können wir ja erstmal berichten, oder auch nicht, sehen wir ja dann. Aber dann zu dem ganz neuesten Snow Labyrinth, gibt es ja hier bei Apple Insider und so, stand das da. Erstens hier diese Screen Recording Feature für QuickTimeX, was ja ganz interessant ist. Aber was ich noch viel interessanter fand, ist, da stand dabei, dass da YouTube Support im OS dabei ist.
Im OS?
Beim iPhone?
Im QuickTimeX, da ist ja, also, jedenfalls spezieller YouTube Support. Hab ich nicht genauer gelesen. Vielleicht hab ich wieder meine Kurzschlüsse.
Meinst du vielleicht das iPhone?
Mein Gedanken zu schnell gefasst. Ich dachte nämlich sofort daran, dass sie das YouTube auch auf dem OS nicht mehr per Flash anzeigen wollen. Also sie wollen sozusagen ein weiteres Gerät schaffen, was Flash eliminiert.
Na das geht ja, das klappt ja auch schon.
Das war mein erster Gedanke. Deswegen hab ich vielleicht nicht richtig reingelesen, was ich hätte tun sollen.
Das heißt Safari 4.
Na ja. Click to Flash kann ja schon jetzt einfach YouTube-Filme mit QuickTime anzeigen. Hat aber leider keine Fullscreen-Funktion.
Was, wie, was?
Du gehst auf eine YouTube-Seite. Mit Click to Flash.
Brauche ich da wie eine neue Version, als die, die ich habe?
Also es geht nicht mit YouTube-Videos, sondern es geht wirklich nur direkt auf der Seite. Gehst auf ein beliebiges Video drauf und dann gehst du mit der rechten Maustaste ins Menü.
Gibt es denn da eine neuere Version?
Na ja, mit der rechten Maustaste. Oder Ctrl-Click.
Dieses hier.
Ah, dann hast du eine altere Version, ich hab eine neuere.
Es gibt ein neues Click to Flash, Jungs! Neueste Nachrichten hier, Shortbreak.
Das ist aber schon durchaus ein bisschen älter.
Wenn die keinen Auto-Updater haben, ich meine...
Okay, dann habt ihr wirklich eine alte Version, die haben lange einen Auto-Updater schon.
Na, da kamen jahrelang keine neuen Versionen.
Dann geht man hier mit...
Ah, 1.4.
Dann geht man hier mit Ctrl-Click drauf, dann hat man Load H264.
Stimmt, hier, Click to Flash, das ist ein WebKit-Plugin, das sich automatisch auf Adobe Flash Content befindet. Ne, steht aber noch nichts von...
Wo ist denn da...
White List, 1,4, hier. Explicit YouTube Support. Explicit Ziffer Support.
Seit wann hat er das? Steht da irgendwo ein Datum daneben?
Also bei 1,4 ist richtig doll viel neu gekommen. Warum sagst du denn nix?
Ja, echt mal.
Datum steht hier natürlich nicht. Das muss ich ja haben. Click to Flash ist ja schon so ein kleines, nettes Gimmick.
Ah, da ist dann auch der Sparkle-Dingst drin.
Genau, das hat Sparkle-Aktualisierung.
Wow, super. Ihr wisst das wahrscheinlich schon alle, aber jetzt auch bei MobileMX angekommen. Die alten Herren haben es jetzt auch mitbekommen. Muss ich jetzt meinen Browser neu starten?
Hat mir mein Vater erzählt.
Hab ich bei meinem Vater gelesen, während er es auf Twitter schrieb.
Während er es von seinem Twitter-4.0-Account auf meinem Twitter-Re-Twitter.
Genau. In der Facebook-Community meines Opas. So, und jetzt muss ich aber alle meine Browser-Fenster wieder beenden und ich hab das Problem, dass mein Safari sich wieder nicht merkt, was ich alles offen habe und deswegen kann ich immer nicht aktualisieren.
Ach, dafür gibt es noch ein anderes schönes Programm, wenn wir hier schon mal dabei sind. Die Erweiterung Glimps heißt die.
Nämlich Kamino.
Install for me only und dann darf ich es nicht auswählen.
Keine Ahnung, was da bei dir ist. Und Glimps ist eine Erweiterung für Safari, mit der man eine Fullscreen-Funktion hat und die auch Tabs abspeichern kann und die Tabs per Apfel-Z wieder öffnen kann, wenn man sie versehentlich geschlossen hat.
Und die funktioniert auch?
Die funktioniert gut. Ist so das erste, was ich immer installiere, wenn ich Safari benutze. Funktioniert mit der Dreier- und Vierer-Version von Safari. Ja, also...
Click to Flash.
Click to Flash, seit zwei Monaten gibt es eine neue Version. Ich weiß nicht, so ewig, wirklich lange.
Aber wann aktiviert sich denn dieser Auto-Update? Immer, wenn man einen Browser neu startet, oder was?
Sicherlich, so kann es sein.
Oder beim ersten Flash, was irgendwie...
Ich glaube beim Starten des Browsers. Und du startest deinen Browser nie neu.
Selten. Ich starte überhaupt selten Programme neu.
Ich starte Programme auch nur selten neu.
Nur wenn sie abstürzen, starte ich sie meist neu.
Na ja, aber du hast ja Safari 4, da passiert das ja ein bisschen öfters mal.
Also, manchmal.
Also ich hab mittlerweile so ein paar Seiten, mit denen ich Safari 4 wirklich in die Knie zwingen kann.
Hat da eigentlich irgendjemand von euch, wir haben ja alle keinen T-Mobile, ne?
Diesen Ausfall, diesen lustigen? Konnten wir am Sonntag keine SMS ohne Ende verschicken?
Scheißgelegte Flash geht bei mir nicht.
Also wir haben das alle irgendwie nicht so richtig mitbekommen, weil... Also ich hab's mitbekommen, weil ich halt Leute nicht erreicht habe. Das war eigentlich alles.
Also ich hab's mitbekommen, weil ich's auf Twitter gelesen habe.
Interessant fand ich allerdings, oder fände ich interessant, also es gab ja eine Erklärung oder zumindest eine Beschreibung, was passiert ist. Hast du das irgendwie verfolgt?
Da ist dieses...
Sie haben irgendwie zwei von drei...
Home Location Server waren das?
Home Location Register, HLRs, sind ihnen irgendwie abgebraucht wegen Softwarefehler.
Die HLRs?
Hab ich gelesen. Ich hab auch irgendwas gelesen von Stromausfall, aber ich glaub, das war dann wohl eher eine Ente.
Der Stromausfall wird wahrscheinlich immer irgendjemand sofort behaupten.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass also Stromausfall in sowas wie im HLR...
HLR ist das Ding, was dafür zuständig ist, sich zu merken, wo sich die Telefone gerade befinden.
Home Location Register, das ist da, wo einfach... Wieviel gibt's davon?
In welcher Zelle ich gerade bin.
Wo du bist und wer du bist.
Drei bei der Telekom.
Die Zahl hab ich gehört, ich kann das nicht bestätigen. Ich weiß das nicht.
Drei Stück für ganz Deutschland. Die haben doch doppelt und dreifach USB da, oder?
Die haben da Dieselgenerator... Ich hab mal einen ganzen Raum voll Säurebatterien mit Strom.
Stromausfall ist halt das, was sie den Leuten erklären, weil da wissen sie, das hat auch Oma schon verstanden.
Nee, sie haben gesagt, das ist...
Ich hab halt beides gelesen. Ich hab halt erst Stromausfall gelesen, das war aber so schnell die Erklärung, dass ich mir dachte, das stimmt bestimmt nicht. Und später stand dann irgendwas von Softwareproblemen, weil sie ja auch durch Reboot das Problem so recht nicht gelöst bekommen haben. Und dann hat es irgendwie sechs Stunden oder so gedauert, bis sie alles wieder hochgezogen bekommen haben.
Ganz schön peinlich.
Das sind die, die uns irgendwie zensurieren wollen.
Das war bestimmt eine Cyber-Attacke.
Aber ich hab gehört, dass sie von der, also ich hab vorhin gerade gehört, dass sie für ihre 85 Millionen kostenlos verschickter SMS, die sie gestern verschickt haben, die hatten ja irgendwie das höchste SMS-Aufkommen aller Zeiten, wenn man gestern umsonst simsen konnte, was sie wahrscheinlich ungefähr 4,80 Euro gekostet hat und haben dafür schön in der Bams eine ganz komplette Seite irgendwie mit Home-Story-Artikeln von dem Techniker, der es versaut hat und wie gut der doch eigentlich ist und weiß der Teufel was. Also sieht so aus, als ob die tatsächlich aus diesem Super-GAU oder aus diesem GAU nochmal schön Kapital geschlagen hätten. Ist das schon ein Super-GAU oder ist das noch GAU?
Ach nee, GAU ist schon anders. Ich meine, so zwei bis sechs Stunden Ausfall der Infrastruktur, das macht ein paar Leute nicht happy, wenn ihnen das jetzt irgendwie nochmal passiert, dann werden sich die Leute schon mal überlegen, was ihr Netz so taugt. Aber ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass so ein Ausfall da viel bewirkt. Da hängen die Leute dann doch sehr an ihren Telefonnummern.
Also GAU. Das Netz liegt klar an, das ist...
Das ist mehr so ein U. Das ist mehr so ein Unfall. Also weißen die ja, GAU keine Ahnung.
Na ja egal, wir brauchen jetzt auch nicht auf irgendwelche Buchstaben zu warten.
Das hängt jetzt wirklich ganz davon ab, was man wirklich als... Ich mein, es geht schlimmer. Schlimmer ist, wenn sie irgendwie ihre Subscriberdaten wegschmeißen. Das ist ein GAU.
Das ist glaube ich schon super GAU.
Wenn sie einfach ihre Kunden danach nicht mehr kennen und die über mehrere Monate sich nicht mehr einbuchen können und sie allen neue SIM-Karten zuschicken müssen oder sonst irgendeinen Scheiß. Also das wäre ein GAU.
Oder wenn sie allen ihre Kunden neue FDP-Zugangsdaten zuschicken, müssten wir ihre Systeme so durchgehackt sind. Was ist denn eigentlich, hast du nicht hier in diesem Podcast nochmal Medon verteidigt vor ganz gar nicht allzu langer Zeit?
Ich hab nur gesagt, dass Medon, dass ich an ihm schätze, dass er so ein harter Kerl ist. Jetzt haben sie halt so ein Weichei da irgendwie reingeballert. Jetzt geht das bestimmt nicht voran mit der Bahn.
Das geht auch so nicht voran.
Boah, ich konnte nicht klagen.
Oh, ich muss noch so eine Runde up-randen.
Kannst du nicht oder wird dein Rechner bewacht?
Jetzt nochmal groß. Alle sind evil irgendwie. Dennis packt aus. Die ganze Wahrheit. Also was ich an so diesen, eigentlich an allen hasse, nicht nur an den großen Firmen, sondern eigentlich überall, ist dieser Psycho-Beschiss, den die halt so betreiben. Also du kaufst halt bei der Bahn die Bahncard und zack, hast gleich ein Abo am Arsch. Ich hätte gar kein Problem damit, so eine Bahncard zu haben. Aber warum muss das gleich ein Abo sein? Und gleich noch so zwanghaft und so geschummelt. Wenn sie das wenigstens groß hinschreiben würden. Junge, das ist ein Abo, du musst ein bisschen aufpassen. Aber ne, es steht irgendwie ganz unten klein.
Zumindest bei der Bahncard 25 und bei der Bahncard 15.
Und es gibt ganz viele andere Sachen auch. Zum Beispiel beim TomTom-Device letztens. Ich klicke irgendwie, er sagte mir, er hätte ja für nur 38 Euro irgendwie neue Maps für mich. Und das wären ja pro Quartal irgendwie nur knappe 9 Euro oder so was. Und dann klicke ich so, das ist ja verdammt billig, was ist denn hier los? Dann klicke ich, dann steht da, um dieses Feature zu kriegen, muss ich aber nochmal für genau exakte gleiche 38 Euro auf den neuesten Stand kommen, um danach irgendwie quartalsmäßig immer Updates zu kriegen. Also eigentlich wollen sie 78 Euro oder irgendwie so. Und das steht dann auch wieder ganz hinten irgendwie. Und was soll denn diese Verarsche? Das ist das, was mich annervt. Keine Probleme, die Wahrheit zu kriegen. Aber von mir aus ist auch mal was teuer. Dann ist es halt teuer, weil die halt irgendwie ordentlich Geld verdienen wollen. Aber dazu müssen sie mich nicht noch irgendwie behandeln, als wenn ich ein Idiot wäre und das nicht durchblicken würde. Das finde ich voll scheiße.
Ich kann dich dann nur unterstützen.
Ja, und das sollen die mal lassen. Weil dann kriege ich nämlich gleich, ich bin nämlich dann ein bisschen bockig. Und dann habe ich nämlich keinen Bock mehr. Und dann kaufe ich das nicht. Obwohl ich wahrscheinlich, wenn der Preis da direkt gestanden hätte, hätte ich gesagt, ja, teuer, hm, okay, ja, ach, shit, kaufen wir halt. Wenn die mich verarschen wollen, habe ich keine Lust mehr. So, jetzt ist es raus.
Es will nicht verarscht werden. Auch nicht von TomTom.
Sehr gut.
Und auch nicht von Click2Flash.
Ja, Click2Flash verarschen dich. Welche Betriebssitz-7-Versionen hast du denn da drauf?
Also bevor wir unser Mobile-Max-Hörer-Treffen announcen. Ach, stimmt ja. Womit wir so langsam auch mal vielleicht das Ende der Sendung einleiten können. Fehlen mir gerade noch ein, habe ich noch ein schönes TIT-Bit gehört, was ich noch nicht kannte. Habe ich auf dem TATS-Kongress mitbekommen. Du warst ja auch kurz da. Schöne Veranstaltung war das.
Die war echt nicht schlecht.
Da waren echt gute Sachen dabei. Und in einer der Veranstaltungen wurde berichtet, damals, 1984, als Apple den Macintosh releasete, haben sie auch in der TATS eine Anzeige geschaltet.
Und zwar?
Welcome to 1984.
Aber nicht wurde diese Zeit, dass mal ein Kapitalist die Welt verändert.
Doch, genau das.
Das habe ich als Plakat noch zu Hause.
Genau, so Marx und Engels irgendwie. Das war eine ganzzeitige... Also ich habe es nicht gesehen, es wurde nur darüber berichtet. Genau, und dann stand halt da der Macintosh, also Marx und Engels. Und dann so, es wurde Zeit, dass auch mal ein Kapitalist die Welt verändert. Und um diese Anzeige in die TATS zu kriegen...
Ach, die haben damals noch keine Anzeigen entgegengenommen?
Doch, natürlich haben sie Anzeigen. Sie haben nicht viele bekommen, das ist ja auch heute noch nicht anders.
Es soll aber auch nicht...
Sie haben aber diese Anzeige, so in der letzten Minute, vor jetzt geht das Ding in Druck, da überhaupt erst reingeschmissen, um zu verhindern, dass die aufmüpfige Redaktion sich sozusagen ischofiert und verhindert, dass das so noch so kommt. Und als das dann so gedruckt wurde, gab es wohl auch richtig Stunk. Aber schönes Ding, oder?
Also das ist ein tolles Plakat. Ich kann es ja mal kurz beschreiben. Ich habe es ja sogar schon gesehen.
Warte mal, das ist doch bestimmt auch...
Das ist auch online.
Und die Internet, oder?
Man sieht so einen Haufen Bücher nebeneinander stehen und quasi als letztes Buch in der gleichen Höhe auch wie die Bücher, ich glaube, so ein bisschen quasi zurecht montiert, steht dann eben der Macintosh da hinter mit seinem Hello.
Schauen wir mal, was das Internet so hergibt. Ist ja immer wieder erstaunlich, was da alles so drin ist, ne?
Also bei mir weigert sich dieses Click-to-Flash.
Tatsache, hier gibt es aber auch auf taz.de einen Text dazu und da kommt hier als erster Link.
Wo finde ich den? Wo ist denn der drin? Weißt du das aus dem Kopf?
Hier kann man sogar bei eBay ersteigern.
Internet Plugins? Was kann man bei eBay ersteigern?
Diese Taz?
Die Taz?
Das Plakat? Das Poster?
Hast du da mal einen Link? Ist das da abgebildet?
Nee, leider nicht.
Aha, na das ist ja toll. Ich seh das hier auch nicht. Aber vielleicht findet das ja irgendjemand.
Ich hab Kapitalist falsch geschrieben. Ich suche mal, ob ich das noch finden kann.
Was war's jetzt eigentlich? Jetzt können wir noch mal sagen, dass wir uns treffen. Wir haben uns geeinigt. Leute, wir machen ein Hörer-Treffen.
Dem hat uns überrumpelt.
Was? Womit?
Mit, dass du nur Sonntagszeit hast.
Ich hab nicht gesagt, dass ich nur Sonntagszeit habe. Ich hab nur gesagt, Sonntags würde mir am besten passen.
Immer wieder Sonntags.
Was schmeust du jetzt? Wollen wir den Termin nicht...
Sonntag ist gut, weil Sonntag ist Wochenende. Ich wäre für... naja, egal. Innerwoche ist auf jeden Fall doof. Und Sonntag ist jetzt...
Sonntag, der?
Der 10. Mai.
Soll es sein?
Das waren alle Details, die wir geklärt haben. Wir haben noch nicht geklärt, wo, oder?
Nee, ich hätte da auch Vorschläge. Aber das werden wir alles... Wo ich auch schon mein letztes Hörer-Treffen gemacht habe. Das war ganz super.
Alle wissen es jetzt nur wir nicht.
Im Übereck.
Also im Prenzlberger Übereck?
Nicht direkt bei mir in der Ecke, aber im Stadtteil.
Was gibt es da im Trei-Designer-Übereck?
Da gibt es A. Platz und B. Internet und nette Leute und guten Milchkaffee und überhaupt.
Ja, kann man doch machen. Das Übereck ist doch nicht so verkehrt. Genau.
Das werden wir alles auch mal bekannt geben über die bekannten Kanäle, die da sind. Unser Blog unter www.mobilestädtichermax.de Max mit CS. Und außerdem sind wir ja auch auf Twitter vertreten. Wie sich das sozusagen heutzutage auch gehört.
Außerdem haben wir noch eine Fax-Abrufnummer.
Genau. Und wer kommentieren will, schreibt das auf eine Postkarte.
Schick die an Ursula von der Leib.
Dann das Treffen mit Max, dem König des Webbs, mit Dennis Darth Vader in Person, mit oder ohne Maske, wird sich noch klären.
Und mit Tim, dem kritischen Blicker.
Ich sitze da rum und schaue skeptisch rein.
Und schleif Diamanten allein mit seinem Blick.
Ich werde sie mir alle anschauen.
Eine Sache loswerden. Da gibt es einen User, der heißt Apfelsäftchen. Und der nutzt mein Logo.
Auf Twitter.
Peer-Pressure, Jungs, macht ihn fertig. Schickt die Sturmtroppen los.
Wie heißt er?
Apfelsäftchen.
Apfelsäftchen, der kann auch keine Katze. Das stimmt, da ist Dennis drauf.
Sag ich das?
Das ist aber doch eine Reminiszenz.
Klar, das ist ein Zeichen, wie cool ich bin. Aber noch viel cooler ist man, wenn man dem das abgewöhnt. Ja, so geht das.
Zack.
Folgt Dennis.
Es gibt nur einen wahren Dennis.
Dennis hat das Web 2.0 verstanden, oder? Dieses kollaborative...
Genau, Dennis, du musst deinen... Jetzt muss er nochmal dein Twitter-Account sagen.
Dennis4223.
Dennis2342. Nur hier echt mit dem Original-Dennis-Logo. Wobei, das ist ja black and white. Das ist ja noch gar nicht so hübsch.
Ja, das ist ja die Schweinerei.
Dennis965 Follower. Kriegen wir jetzt, wenn du noch ein freundliches Tschüss sagst, dann kriegst du die Schild noch auf tausend.
Ja, aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen, ganz ehrlich, entfollow Dennis, wenn er hier tatsächlich sowas auffordert und nicht das Ganze als Scherz-Out. Das finde ich...
Du meinst, in Zeiten von Pirate Bayen...
Ja, also hier die ganze Zeit für Pirate Bayen.
Wie kann man sich denn ein Bild von jemandem klauen, der man nicht selber ist?
Vielleicht mag er dich einfach.
Das machen die Internet eine ganze Menge Leute.
Von dir gibt es auch Leute, die dein Bild benutzen?
Ne, das nicht.
Jungs, benutzt mal das Bild von Timme. Der findet das nämlich toll.
Naja, man nimmt ja Bilder von Leuten, die einem sexy und cool erscheinen lassen.
Außerdem hat er da ein bisschen Bauch weggenotiert.
Quatsch nicht.
Jungs, das Niveau sinkt, die Stimmung steigt. Es ist Zeit, ein Ende zu setzen. Der 26. Ausgabe von Mobamix.
Ich volle jetzt hier mal Apfelsäfchen.
Die wir nennen werden Zensursula. Was übrigens nicht von mir ist, wie ich heute auch nochmal bekannt geben muss.
Was muss man eigentlich machen um CCC-Mitglied? Ich wollte ja CCC-Mitglied werden.
Da schreibst du eine Postkarte. Das ist jetzt kein Witz. Nein, es gibt da also einen Antrag.
Ja, den Antrag habe ich mir ausgedruckt. Ja, aber das ist jetzt hier nicht der Kars Computer Club.
Und da schreiben sie hier, hier und hier.
Und das war's.
Wahrscheinlich im Übereck, so gegen 19 Uhr.
Genau, ein Tag vor der nächsten Sendung. Und da könnt ihr uns dann erzählen, was wir alles zu erzählen haben. Und wir berichten dann toll in der nächsten Ausgabe vom Hörer treffen für Leute, die nicht dabei sein können.
Vielleicht findet sich auch jemand, der Dennis beim Click-to-Flash installieren hilft.
Genau, und vielleicht haben alle Mobile-Max-Hörer morgen Dennis Logo in ihrem Twitter-Account.
Oder Tim!
Siehst du, dass es das passiert, wenn man probiert, Informationen aus dem Netz rauszunehmen.
Dir geht es nicht anders als share.
Ich seh schon. Das war mein Trick, um berühmt zu werden jetzt. Tschüssi. Für die 35 Follower.